have some announcements here regarding
uh our total load which we have here we
have one new bill that came to us uh
hp218 is a bill that's referenced
establishing an early educated
professional development grant program
that is what we call an early bill so
we're going to have to get that out by
the early Bill deadline
um
which is the see it's in committee
what's that early date I don't have a
calendar in front of you what's the
early date for us it's May 11th so that
bill has to be up by on May 11th we also
have another early bill as well that's
151 which we'll be hearing this morning
that is an early bill as well and uh
that will be the second bill which we
discussed this morning that deals were
relative to mental health education
so we had two early bills a total of 16
bills in education for this this uh this
uh spring which is a relief that we
didn't get any more than that
yeah so that's added on to what we have
we're a little bit less than what we had
last year where we had 130 39 bills
okay so we're just waiting for our clerk
to arrive here
um
as I said we have the first bill up is
going to be
um today is 1 35 that's relative to
Alternative dispute resolution and
special education
so I think we're going to go ahead and
start hearing that and when the clerk
gets in your uh representative Ford
would you please just take notes as far
as there's a there's one sheet there
which I had out
you know this all daisy chain so that
once you're speaking ears and see what
foreign
check testing one two
yeah
testing
good
check testing one two crack look is it
okay with that we're going to go ahead
and open up the hearing process for
today uh being April the 11th
uh we have the first bill which is one
SB 135 relative to Alternative dispute
resolution in special education and
Senator Ward who is busy downstairs has
her administrative assistant here is
that your capacity daily majority Cox
director majority caucus director okay
welcome and that's
f-r-e-n-e-t-t-e yes okay thank you
foreign
chairman Ladd members of the committee
my name is Daley frenette and I am the
Senate majority majority caucus director
I'm here today to introduce Senate Bill
135 on behalf of Senator Ward
when parents in school districts are in
conflict over the provision of special
education the law provides for
alternative dispute resolution in the
form of neutral conference and mediation
the implementation of the alternative
dispute resolution processes fall within
the purview of the Department of
education's office of dispute resolution
and constituent complaints
the Department's alternative dispute
resolution processes are flexible
confidential and informal processes in
which an impartial third party assess
parents and school districts to resolve
a conflict
the trained alternative dispute
resolution officer's goal is to help the
parties to explore the issues and
ultimately where possible to resolve the
issues the goal throughout is to open up
communication and reduce conflict
between the parties
Senate Bill 135 would add in a provision
that would allow for a continuance of
the relevant process if mutually agreed
to buy the parties this will provide for
more flexibility in scheduling sessions
as the current 30-day limitation can
hinder successful resolution
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak today and I'll look
for any questions to members of the
department who are in attendance today
thank you
um I do have a copy of your your
testimony there which we could submit
for the record absolutely great thank
you
I suspect we do have the department here
so if we have questions and perhaps we
ought to direct them in that area uh the
thank you
yep
so we have a combination here
good morning
thank you for the opportunity you assure
my con
it is now can you hear me yep yeah you
might just direct it towards you though
that's okay don't worry about that
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with you today I'm administrator of the
opposite dispute resolution and
constituent complaints for the
Department of Education
part of my role includes administering
the alternative dispute resolution
process for the Department of Education
and State Board of Education
um
New Hampshire is an alternative dispute
resolution processes are meant to be
flexible confidential and informal
processes uh which an internal in in
partial third party assist parents and
school districts to resolve a conflict
and sometimes Educators as well
alternative dispute resolution process
sessions can be done through mediation
as part of a due process hearing
Standalone mediation neutral conference
and a third party discussion led by
moderator
um the goal is to help parties to
explore the issues and ultimately where
possible to resolve the disputes they
may bring an attorney with them to any
of the alternative dispute resolution
processes
parents and Guardians may also bring an
advocate supported decision maker or
anyone else that they feel will be a
support with them if they choose to do
so
sometimes what this does is it causes
the timelines to
in doubt needing to be extended because
you have so many people that want to be
part of the mediation
the desired outcome throughout is to
open up communication reduce conflict
between the parties and ultimately for
the parties to resolve the problem and
put their agreement in writing
the change in language to Senate Bill
135 to include the opportunity for
parties to mutually agree to schedule it
to continue a schedule will be
beneficial to the parties there are
times when one day of mediation for
example does not afford the parties
enough time to dissolve resolve the
dispute
for example a second day of mediation
beyond the established 30-day window may
be all that is needed to resolve the
dispute additionally parties are often
accompanied by Council who for whatever
reason previous case or Court
commitments is unavailable for dates
previously agreed to by the parties
other times a rescheduled beyond the
statutory 30-day time frame may be
required due to a necessary expert or
School official on leave or other
required commitments or a parent with
work of family constraints
sometimes a follow-up session or
sessions is necessary to hammer out
details on especially difficult cases
involving IEP individualized education
plans placement and compensatory
Services there are instances where
parties are in agreement on a placement
of program but before final signatures
can be applied to the final agreement
they are waiting on Expert reports or
openings to an approved non-public
school placement that may take more than
30 days
the change to RSA 186c 23 would remedy
those challenges to the limitations of
the 30-day time frame
thank you that's all I have
anything else from the Department I'm
really just playing the role of a potted
plant it's really nice when
um Stephen and I work together and he's
just so incredibly competent there's not
much more for me to say or do here but I
think it's great when we the department
has the opportunity to bring people
forward to these committees so that you
can see the the faces behind the behind
all the hard work Stephen has done an
amazing job building up this program and
facilitating this program and he's happy
to answer any questions that this
committee thank you I do have one
um when we have to go this route to get
some resolution by the term parties who
are the parties is it's who's bringing
this forward uh the school district or
the mediator can you explain what's your
definition of parties is sure that's a
fair question uh generally speaking it's
parents our party and the school
district so they're the two main parties
to the hearing or it to the mediation a
lot of times mediation is is through the
due process hearing process but a lot of
times it's Standalone as well and they
can have neutral conference moderator
session or mediation it depends upon
what they want so back to the initial
question yes party is largely the
parents the student and the school
district so those would be the parties
it is is
the legal advice being given to the par
of the parent part of the party or is in
other words if the attorney can't be
there at the scheduled time is that
cause for moving this beyond the 30 days
yes that does happen a lot where parent
attorneys are unavailable and so they
ask for continuance however that's also
true that school district attorneys
sometimes
need an extension because they're not
able to make it on that time
having said that when they file the
request for mediation if it's Standalone
mediation they are requested to provide
three to four mutually agreed upon dates
and then with those dates we reach out
to whoever the person is it's going to
be the mediator the neutral or the
moderator to see whether they can meet
on those dates and if so it gets
scheduled
so what happens with the request for
continuances sometimes comes about after
it's already been scheduled
maybe because of the question about
largely these are placement issues there
could be assessment issues whether the
child needs a different coding
um so there's a variety of reasons why
they reschedule
it's not something that we like at the
department because we like to have
things done as soon as possible but this
is for the parties that's the reason
we're bringing it forward for for
parents as well as school districts
thank you Steve are there questions
representative Miler well thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here and
taking my question I really have three
questions one is who are the mediators
during these sessions uh one two how
many uh incidents do you have how many
of these interventions do you have in a
given year and what percent of those
interventions need this extended period
of time
so the mediators also act as hearing
officers but if they are
assigned as mediators they will not be
the hearing officer in the case
you currently we have six individuals
they're all attorneys
uh
and some of them have been with us for a
number of years some are new
um contract is coming up in July so
we'll have an additional and then two uh
well actually one has passed away
uh we'll have one less two less actually
in terms of what was the second question
of these types of matters come forward
every year I would say we have about 30
to 40. alternative dispute resolution I
can get those numbers to you that's fine
thank you
um and I would say that the majority
like how many actually need a
continuance percentage-wise the
percentage-wise how many need a
continuance probably 85 to 90 percent
really yeah thank you very much
further questions yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
I think the
the heart of this that I that I don't
fully understand
is that if there's because the way the
way the law reads us currently we're
talking about students whose parents
have rejected either an IEP educational
placement identification or evaluation
of a child so I'm I'm trying to
understand is this something that is
utilized when the school wants to move
forward with these and the parent does
not want any of these or is it or is it
more along the lines of the school wants
to move forward and the parents want to
move forward but with a different plan
so I think largely it's initiated by
parents
because they want something that the
school district does not want to agree
to
and so under under the law they have a
right to mediation through due process
hearing as well as Standalone so for
example parent wants their child to not
be
um
placed in the school district they want
their child to go to another school that
may be better you know an outside
placement and that would be subject to a
mediation
uh or for example the IEP there's
something that the parent wants in the
IEP or some services and the school
district says no or reading Specialists
or things like that and so apparent that
can be open for mediation what we try to
do because the federal government the
U.S Department of Education is really
keen on trying to negotiate instead of
going through a full due process hearing
that whenever you have the opportunity
to try to negotiate to resolve disputes
that's their goal and they make we at
the state have to set goals every year
to what
um you know 80 percent of the cases need
to be mediated that's the goal of the
federal government
that's not necessarily what occurs sure
if I if I may because I think I heard
the the important answer and I want to
make sure I heard it correctly so these
are these are initiated by parents not
by schools no they're by parents and
schools but largely by parents that have
a dispute with the school district
because the school district does not
want uh to for example pay for
replacement or if reading Specialists or
a special assessment a sec you know
outside uh I'm not an expert with
special ed so I I just have to be either
too much
yeah either party but in large part what
we see are parents filing if I may just
please once more just to clarify further
so the circumstances under which a
school might file to go through this
process would it be a circumstance
perhaps where a parent does not want
their child evaluated or placed in an
IED IEP program but the school wants to
move forward with it
and negotiate with them towards that end
no sometimes what happens is that like
for example
um there is a safety issue the school
district May request a hearing and
mediation could be part of that
um
I I have to be cautious because I'm not
like again Natasha lupiani my my
colleague that handles special ed
complaints is the expert in Special Ed I
do everything so I can't like I do
manifest educational hardship I do all
kinds of uh regular education issues but
special education is not my forte
although
um you know clearly as administrator
overseeing the hearings process I have
that role I will say that what I see
largely are IEP issues service issues
placement and it's largely parents that
are requesting
thank you representative cascadden do
you have a question just wanted to add
that it's not necessarily
um in a special ed situation it's the
school district tries to develop a
program or provide Personnel that's
going to meet the needs of that child
for them to make progress and if the
parents have their mindset on something
totally different
that's where you need a hearing officer
but generally the school really bends
over backwards to accommodate the needs
of the child but the parents might have
an idea that the needs of the child are
something different
so and no evaluation can be done without
parent permission so I just wanted to
add that representative cordelli
thank you thank you both for being here
on a Monday morning
um we've had discussions about who are
allowable participants in an IEP meeting
have there been issues as to
um who can participate in mediation
discussions thinking particularly you
mentioned about the parents can bring an
activist
an advocate or a lawyer have there been
issues in that regard that you're aware
of
so we changed the form
and added a box on the form for all of
our
alternative dispute resolution processes
that parents can sign I I want to attend
mediation with an attorney or I want to
have a mediation for example without an
attorney
and the hope of that is that then the
school district may see that and say
well if they're not going to bring an
attorney we won't
but we can't require that the answer is
they can bring whoever they wish
um so if they if they want to have an
advocate or if they want to have their
grandparent and sometimes that's
happened before
they can bring whomever they want
they just at the initiation of a
mediation will request that they file
out the pay file the paperwork that
states who the parties are and then who
is going to be with the parties to speak
yes I just wonder can we get a copy of
that form
sure thank you further questions from
the committee
Nancy thank you very much thank you
you're very welcome thank you and I
don't have any other pink cards up here
on SB 135 so with that I'm going to
close the hearing
and we will be opening up uh SB 151 in
we're going through one of these up in
Haverhill right now where the parent
okay we're going to go ahead with this
relative to mental health education and
I welcome Senator Waters well good
morning thank you Mr chair members of
the committee nice to see you all I'm
Senator David Waters from District Four
to introduce Senate Bill
151 relative to mental health uh
education
um the bill simply adds mental health
explicitly to our adequate education
statutes on sound Wellness
and health
and let me just give a little background
about how this bill came
um to be it certainly is in part of
response to what we're hearing from our
schools and from our youth about
increasing issues not just from from
covert times because these have been
some trend lines about issues around
mental health that have been noticed in
our in our schools
um and you know we know that about one
in six United States youth experience a
mental health disorder
each year we've dealt with issues of
bullying certainly uh in the in the
legislature that can that contributes um
we know the tragic statistics about
youth suicide and attempted
um suicides and if you look to the youth
risk behavior survey you get a little
finer grid on what our students are are
reporting
um
34 felt sad or hopeless 18 seriously
considered suicide seven percent
attempted
suicide these are affected by the
substantial rates we have in the state
of substance
misuse drugs and alcohol
um
and 23 percent experience fully on
campus 20 percent
um excuse me a 10 experienced sexual
violence uh seven percent were
physically forced to have
sexual intercourse so these are fact
these are factors and uh you know
there's there's a lot of a lot of
difficulties that our youth are
are um facing and we do teach Health in
schools and so it seems that schools are
very effective and efficient place in
order for us to make sure that we're
providing
um students with the understanding need
of mental health uh just disorders
um but also so they can recognize
um these issues in themselves and
perhaps in their in their peers I've
gone to school in some ways on the
peer-to-peer program some Dover for
example Dover High has a student Club
where they do daily check-ins with other
students and ask the kind of questions
about how you doing today and and they
are trained to understand what some of
the signs may be and they can offer
some conversation or or some reference
to help the students might be able to
get if they're if they're having certain
feelings or haven't had certain
experiences
I think particularly because of the
contributing factor of uh drug and
alcohol misuse disorders which are high
in this in this state I serve on the
governor's commission alcohol and and
other drugs and we regularly do fund
groups in the schools that try to help
with peer-to-peer counseling and
educational programs and those factors
so as we all know you know mental health
and other factors are are combined here
one of the real Inspirations for this um
has been in some ways the governor's
leadership
um he had conversations with his
Governor's youth advisory commission and
um they brought up the issue of what
they're hearing about mental health and
the government was particularly
concerned and asked kind of asked the
council to look into mental health
issues
um and to in their report to him to make
some recommendations about what what
could be done to address mental health
uh education in the schools so that
report was sent to the to the governor
in accordance with his desire to work on
this and again I want emphasize because
my work with the governor on Alcohol and
Other Drugs and mental health issues
that you know this is something that
he's really concerned about for our
youth and so that's that's the um the
origin of the bill so let's turn to the
bill itself and I'll I'll just talk
through the approach that is taken
um I think it's going to be very helpful
to us to have mental health here in
these two places in the inadequacy
um yes under education rules there is a
discussion of mental health in the
Health curriculum but what was reported
in the investigations that the
governor's youth advisory council did at
the behest of the governor was that it
was very spotty as to whether mental
health was being treated in health
education
whether the teachers had adequate
information
and capacity to teach it whether they
had accurate information up to date
information on the issues that the youth
are are facing so as we have done with
other aspects of um adequacy uh having
it in here and then directing that there
be a curriculum made available is a way
to make sure that we're helping our our
students
um
then what it asks here is for the
Department to make the rules and you'll
see there's a rather comprehensive list
here of the issues that emerge around
mental health so that the curriculum
that is provided can provide good
accurate information for the schools on
these on these subjects
the bill was also structured this way
kind of looking back to what we did on
child sexual abuse prevention education
we're wanting to avoid an unfunded
mandate for our local schools we took
this similar path
and though on a different subject a
couple years ago the chairman and I
worked on outdoor recreation being
included in adequacy but the same
pattern it was not requiring the local
student districts to Bear the expense of
developing that curriculum but
established a pattern where by it could
be done in cooperation with the
community college system and and other
folks as well so that was the that was
the model here
um to have the the rule making
um that that would that would be done
and I'll talk a little bit more about
the FI the fiscal note in a moment and I
think very importantly at the bottom of
um the first page here the parental
consent
um I'm really very grateful to Senator
gendro and Senators Lang in Senate
education along the other members there
who said well let's button this up about
parental rights you know we already have
in statute as you see here the parents
have to be able to have the right to opt
into this or you know into this
curriculum and so the idea as you'll see
in the bowl there at the very end this
paragraph shall specifically apply to
any course material mental health now
one might say that's a little redundant
but I think it's useful I mean I I you
know having been a parent myself and
parental consent
parental rights we have a lot of
conversation about that and I think
particularly in this area that's
important to have you want to make sure
that the parents know and parents want
their their children to have good mental
health education but they want to know
what that's going to involve and whether
you know how they how their own family
beliefs and culture would feel about
that so that's what's that's what's
there uh in the substance of it let me
talk about the the physical note
and um you know I want to start with
that I this bill derived from a lot of
conversations with commissioner Ada blue
and others
um with nami and various folks about and
with the governor's youth advisory
Council about how how do we do and what
do we include and um I really appreciate
the guidance of commissioner adabu and
others on how to get this bill to a
place that it would it would work for
the Department of Education
um I will say that I had not anticipated
the physical note that's why I had not
put an appropriation here I wanted to
avoid any unfunded mandate and um
thought there would not be necessarily
such a cost in finding available
curricula online that then then could be
posted as a link for educators to use
with some with some guidance as I said
we've done before
since the time the um additional
conversations with Department of
Education about about the cost and
um and just in order it came through
fine Senate Finance we knew about this
uh unanimously as well as the policy
um committee and um since that time I
started to look around and see okay what
what is being provided out there across
the country and you may have a letter
from Meet marrow
um and that is one company I've had some
conversation with that provides online
curriculum uh and education before
teachers in how to deliver that
curriculum and they are have a capacity
in what they do to tailor and to look at
what state statute is what to require
what they can do what they can't do and
to tailor their any curriculum they
offer electronically to the actual
requirements of the state there are
other places to do this so I think the
opportunity is there
um and I've had conversation with a
member of Senate Finance we have his in
the house we have an add-on with list
where things that emerge between the
beginning of the budget and when the
Senate deals with it we have add-ons and
um I have the conversation about we'll
put this on the add-on list so that um
that that funding can be provided into
the budget
that said I will say that
I think it's a small price to pay
for mental health education
if we can help one student
not contemplate suicide or act on those
feelings if we can help some students
deal with substance abuse or disorder or
help students deal with the other issues
that they're seeing or with their peers
I I think that's that we've done
something very good and and also you
know mental health education like health
education is is Lifetime education isn't
it the school the skills that they're
going to learn in school will help them
for the rest of their lives so Saturday
once along Mr chairman but I wanted to
kind of address each of those issues
thank you very much before I take any
questions I do have one
I'm trying to determine where the line
is here between the responsibilities of
the school psychologist
and that of the classroom teacher now I
looked at Ed 306 that's our education
rules for and it says School
psychologists shall provide
Comprehensive Psychological Services
throughout various environments and it
goes on and it identifies those and the
school psychologist is also trained of
course and and a member of the National
Association of school psychologist as
its reference in the 8306 which has
principles for professional ethics
these individuals are very well
qualified and that's to deal with
students with mental issues and I agree
that mental issues in our schools is is
growing and it's an issue that has to be
addressed
is this bill opening up the door however
to allow a classroom teacher to take on
some of these responsibilities that
they're not trained for
um and that's that's my question and how
how can we find out where that line is
so that we don't end up with
teachers saying well you know I I was
just trying to address this at any basic
component of an adequate education
and then somebody come back and say well
you know you don't have the skill to do
that yeah so let's answer your question
and it really is an essential question
and I'll say a couple things about it
um
I think education and treatment are
absolutely different and there should be
a bright line between the two
and the school psycho psychologists is
someone who I think is there to help
students find treatment
this is about educational understanding
what mental health is
about educational understanding
some of the kind of issues that you may
notice in yourself or in others and to
give you a way of of go you know each of
those topics there to understand what
psychological impacts may be about that
if someone
exhibits
a condition
or feels that they are trouble by
condition that's not for a teacher
Heavens no
um it's for the school psychologist
school psychologist is not going to be
able to teach how many thousands of
students or hundreds of students of a
curriculum in the classroom so I I think
I agree with you if you if you feel that
there's um
necessary to add a line here that says
that curriculum shall not involve nor
shall teachers be involved in the in the
um
advising or treating of students for
mental health issues of course
but you know it's like we have health
education I mean there are physical
therapists right you know that somebody
in the football teams gets hurt physical
therapist but they're not doing the
health education for him so I think it's
kind of an equivalent there Mr chairman
thank you very much either questions
represent Myler
uh thank you representative Aladdin
thank you for taking my question I want
to kind of follow up on on the previous
question
first of all thank you for bringing this
bipartisan bill before us today
how do you respond to those who say
mental health is not should not be an
issue within schools you kind of
indicated that you know teachers aren't
qualified to be mental health
professionals Etc so how do you respond
to that to the senator
bro come thanks for the question and you
know
um
whether we wanted to be in the schools
or not
mental health issues are affecting our
students
and as an educator
no matter what really you know we're
talking about health education but any
kind of education I think we can our
idea is to provide the tools in adequate
education that a student is going to
need
um to succeed academically but also with
life skills that's why we do outdoor
recreation that's why we do Wellness
right
um so I I think that it's inevitable but
also I as I suggested earlier the school
is a very good place to provide this
education
and you know I we heard very strongly
from students that the teaching that is
being done now under existing rules is
not adequate it in some cases we heard
from students who in their
entire time in school had never had any
instruction in mental health and
precious little
in other kinds of health or Wellness
so
um I think we can improve that without
expecting teachers to be experts in
mental health treatment but certainly
teachers know how to how to teach if
they're given the curricular resources
that they that they need
thank you representative cascadden thank
you Mr chair and thank you senator for
taking my question
um I'm looking through this as a lens
that there is another it's another bill
to add another social service within the
public school system and that's how I'm
worried about it being received on that
end because the school day has not
gotten any longer and God knows in the
last 10 15 years how many more
requirements have been put on public
school staff and then transition that to
an area that is low socioeconomic where
a psychologist and a guidance counselor
is not always on staff or is shared with
multiple buildings
I'm thinking where is this going to be
implemented so so I'm thinking okay one
you need to be able to have access to a
psychologist who works with children or
I mean that the standards say one
Elementary School can have up to 500
students in a day of 500 students that
counselor has a zero type plus they're
not trained as therapists like a school
psychologist
so that raises a question for me as to
how can how how do you propose that this
be done in schools who don't have the
funding for the bare minimums of
optional Services based on statute I
mean School psychologists and school
guidance counselors are optional
Services by Statute
um so I guess I I have that question
and then I'd rather I have to tell you
I'd rather see a bill that requires all
teachers to be trained in youth Mental
Health First Aid
um yeah but yeah how would we staff that
in a yeah you know I just see where and
the state should provide that that
training thank you and oh I'm sorry
you know I I
I you know lifetime I don't know there's
a question but how would this happen 44
years in the classroom you know and uh
and um you know worked on education in
my 14 years up here and I think you're
pointing to a a real kind of struggle
about how how our what capacity to our
schools have to deliver education and um
I would like to note that given what we
know about what's happening with our
youth definitely we've got to do
something yeah it definitely and I think
what's important about this is just
again to reiterate that we are not
expecting
a creation of a treatment system
we're not expecting schools for this
bill to become a Social Service Agency
we are saying schools do what you do
teach students so they have the facts
about mental health about wellness and
about these factors
um about drug and alcohol use about
violence of various of various sorts
about suicide per se or you know or or
really the positive sides of Wellness
you know I mean the things you can do to
feel better you know and um uh and and I
think that that's a curricular issue
and I wanted very much as I said to
structure this so we are not asking
schools with unfunded mandate to hire
lots of new teachers to train them to
make them go through this and that I
think that this model works very well if
you provide teachers with a really good
online curriculum and again I say you
know did meet Mero is just what I know
about because I want them played around
on their website but there are others
you can find out there and you'll see
this is a they can provide a good
curriculum and um that's why but what's
important is it goes through the funnel
the Department of Education
which I have full confidence in can
develop you know and post the model
curriculum and they're willing to put
some effort into it with a hundred
thousand dollars you know to make sure
that we get what can work for our
teachers
um I think clearly we all know the
Mental Health crisis in the state we've
got to do a whole lot more about all
kinds of services and so on and that's a
big issue and I will say the governor is
working hard on that one too but here in
the schools we can we can do this I
think this can work
follow up please yes go ahead
um so is the intent of the bill to add
this in adequacy so that it
follows that adequacy formula as a yeah
so if you're part of adequate education
yeah if you look at the um if you look
at the bill on um
page one
you see the existing language yep the
sound wellness and as the chair pointed
out well and had they had rules that was
you know there's some talk about mental
health but sound Wellness but then
adding mental health explicitly there
and then a little bit further down
Health wellness and mental health
so in in um
those those places it what it does is it
Keys up
that their new spirit curriculum
then it needs to be taught and we're
going to provide you with the tools you
need to do that so that that's the way
the bill structured
okay luno and then represent cordiello
thank you
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Senator
um why did the um I was looking at the
at the bills amended by the Senate and
looking at the bill is introduced and um
and given that it's got a I think a long
slate of bipartisan you know sponsors
why was um why was the original section
one
um removed from the bilicas that looks
like it provided a lot of context for
this well thanks for the question and
you know findings are findings they
don't go into statute and um the
committee thought that really the heart
of the bill is in the list of topics
that you're asking the Department of
Education to include when they make
their rules and you know also in that
those findings uh since the time I wrote
the Bill
who are based on the 2019 risk use
Behavior survey guess what about three
weeks ago the 2021
numbers came out and things are pretty
much the same kind of difference so I
think it made some some sense that you
know the findings
um
were seen as a little extraneous and I
think that also the Senate education you
know Senator Lyon Senator General were
particularly concerned about not to be
distracted in some ways by topics and
the findings and to because here's what
we want to actually be done and here it
I think most importantly was the
parental consent
that those were the issues that became
the core of the bill and the rest of it
kind of fell away there you go represent
cordiall yes thank you Mr chair um if
it's okay I sort of have a two-part
question about two different phrases
here so um thank you senator for taking
my questions
um on the first page of the actual bill
line 28 there is a phrase
at the parents expense and this is in
regards to if a parent opts out in
writing
uh um in objection to some material they
have to
um
requires them an alternative agreed upon
by the school district and the parents
so
the parent if
if a parent UPS their child out they're
required to provide a different
curriculum at their at their expense and
doesn't this place a barrier to those of
a lower income that's a motivation for
that that's that's existing statute
that's this bill doesn't change that at
all okay well maybe we need to change
there
um okay so then maybe I'm new at this so
just
um is this is the same the case with to
the extent practicable on page two then
because that's where the school district
shall make curriculum course materials
available to parents or legal Guardians
my question was going to be in what sort
of situation would it be impractical to
provide these materials but if this also
is an existing statute I guess that goes
beyond this hearing and
yeah but let us know that what's
important here is that you know the
Senate felt that it was important to
make sure that parents knew that as they
do in general in health education but
particularly here to make sure parents
know that's why the bullet is there
here's the existing and we put it here's
the existing language
that protects parents and their rights
and just to button it up by saying that
also includes Mental Health
so but that is existing statute I'm sure
the chairman can tell you the many many
years in which we struggled to come up
with that language and and extend
practicable and why that phrase and um
yeah yeah but it's existing represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for being here
um
so uh just to briefly follow up on rip
portiello and her question yeah the the
expense of a new curriculum that may be
existing language but this new
requirement would be applicable under
that existing language would that be
correct So It ultimately would then
require a parent to substitute their own
curriculum if they opt out okay like
anything else perfect we want to provide
that up top but they gotta you know they
gotta they gotta pass the interest
they've got to demonstrate they have an
adequate education so excellent if I may
do my original question
um the new language specifically calls
for the teaching
on line 17 Page One mental health coping
strategies including personal practices
um would you agree that that constitutes
the practice of mental health within the
classroom
well thanks for the question you see
that section is the things that deal we
ought to consider in making their rules
and selecting the curriculum so that's
why I entrust this to doe to figure out
what
you know I mean these are these are good
questions it's good to have coping
skills huh
yeah and uh and so
um this is a a way as we do and you know
as in physical health education right I
mean we teach student skills how to keep
themselves physically hit and um so I I
am entrusting doe here to look at this
kind of laundry list and figure out okay
how do how do we
put online a curriculum that touches on
his issues and then of course a teacher
is going to have the freedom and this
local school board to decide how to use
that curriculum and how to apply it to
what they're going to do in the
classrooms if I made just one more one
last question um
he brought up physical education and I I
totally agree and that's a that's a
solid thing we always need to be
teaching students but would you agree
that unlike physical education
requirements mental health requirements
is much more liable to be bumping up
against ideological and potential
religious objections that parents could
have
well thank you um
I worry about it and that's why that's
why the solution that Senator gender and
Lang came in here is just to make it
make it sure that that Stu the parents
that may have some concerns about that
have the opportunity
to see that and um and I think the
Department of Education will be very
cognizant of that as as well and um
so
yes I mean let's let's do it so the
parents can understand that this is this
is this is serving we call it it's
mental health and
but it is education and it's education
that we is believed will help your we
help your children out
um with their life skills
and with their knowledge base I mean
there's a lot of stigma around mental
health right there's a lot of autonomous
information around it autonomous
information around alcohol and drug
abuse a lot of
maybe not enough information about
Suicidal Thoughts so anyhow I mean I I
Let's help our Let's Help the students
out and um I really again as I can't
emphasize how much I trust commissary
double and the doe staff to figure out
on a curriculum that's appropriate to
help our our young people out thank you
for that are the questions from the
committee
that's yes representative Cascade
just to get your perspective Senator
um
if it's an added curriculum
to the school
I mean where do you draw the line on
what's
parents should be doing versus what the
school would be doing do you see any
well that's the question and I mean that
that is kind of always
I mean in almost any form of Education
that's always an issue because you want
parents to be involved and um and
parents want to be involved and uh
and um you know you want these people to
be mutually reinforcing and informative
um
I think that this bill is a fairly light
touch by incorporating mental health as
an articulated aspect of health
education so it's not saying replace
health education it's an aspect of it
right and within that context
um teachers
through the doe kind of guidance because
of what is going to be the online
curriculum that's made available to them
can develop in the context of the local
schools the appropriate balance there
um so I mean I don't see in some ways I
mean you ask great questions because in
some ways but it's not I'm just trying
to not a whole lot different from what
we face in all areas of the curriculum
just about lately yes
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions representative
thank you Mr chair thank you again
senator for taking my question would um
would you object to um maybe and I know
we're executing this later this morning
maybe adding the term other or the
condition Eating Disorders to somewhere
on line 16.
which which is the area where it lists a
um
you know I I uh I I obviously it's an
important aspect and for young people
certainly
um as I said I this became I went to
Mental Health
sources an educational source to make
this list it may not be comprehensive if
the committee thinks that it's good to
articulate that
um I suspect health professionals would
think that's a pretty good idea but you
know I the wisdom of this committee look
let me just say Mr chairman
I hope we pass the Bill okay
we're gonna help our spoon salad
the committee feels that there's some
some things that need to be done to
increase your comfort level
um then I'm I'm you know I'm certainly
going to be open Senator do you want to
read the only reason I'm asking is
because I think there's two numbers on
the back of student ID cards one of them
is The Suicide Prevention Hotline and
the second one may be eating disorders
hey so so I mean I'm comfortable with
the bill as is but I think it should be
consistent I appreciate that that is in
our mission and thank you and and I do
have one last one for you because this
is something that you as the sponsor
decided to do you decided to put this in
193 E2 adequacy in our statutes why did
you not opt to put it in 189 10 studies
where we already mentioned health
education
um thanks for your uh question Mr
chairman I thought here this is the kind
of governing
statute for adequacy and I thought that
that that's why I belonged here and
after the drafting attorney thought
um though I think
you know that's it's it's a useful
question and I'm
okay thank you with that we have some
other cards so we're going to Center you
thank you chairman Latin committee
members for the opportunity to testify
today for the record my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm the public policy assistant
at Nami New Hampshire the National
Alliance on Mental Illness
Nami is a non-profit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy
on behalf of Nami I'm here today to
speak in support of SB 151
earlier this session I came before the
committee to speak in support of a
similar bill hb505 which the committee
then retained while we still support HP
505 we believe that the differences in
SB 151 May successfully address concerns
the committee had regarding the prior
bill
despite mental health education being
required by administrative rule the Nami
New Hampshire has heard from several
students who indicate that they've had
zero mental health education within the
health education program in their
schools considering our current youth
Mental Health crisis this education must
be provided
one in six U.S youth ages 6 to 17
experience a mental health disorder each
year and suicide is the second leading
cause of death for granite Staters ages
10 to 34.
further emerging New Hampshire data
shows alarming leaps in all suicide
related artem's items for 9th to 12th
grade students from 2019 to 2021. I
won't go over those exact numbers but
they are there
by codifying these adequate education
requirements SB 151 would ensure that
every school provides this critical
education increasing knowledge of in
reducing the stigma surrounding mental
illness
with regards to HP 505 the committee was
concerned with the use of the word
comprehensive and that the bill did not
provide specific guidance on what topics
should be included SB 151 however does
not use the word comprehensive and
provides a list of specific mental
health subjects to be addressed in the
curriculum additionally this bill
specifically includes an opt-out option
for parents and families who find the
content objectionable
to improve the well-being and future of
New Hampshire Youth and Young adults we
need all hands on deck including the
state schools by requiring mental health
education and statute this bill is one
tool that can be used to help address
the youth Mental Health crisis New
Hampshire is experiencing therefore we
urge the committee to vote OTP on SB 151
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
yes represent dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking a question
um I was reading the comments from the
hearing in the Senate and Holly Stevens
testified behalf of your organization
there and
um Senator Ward asked uh how much time
would be proper for a course or lecture
like this and how over how long a basis
which would this be is this one year one
class one quarter one semester and the
response was that they'd find out and
get back to the committee so I wondered
if they'd done that I'm not sure if if
Holly did that I can connect with her
and ask though and if we have that
recommendation I can pass it on to you
as well okay thank you for your question
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here
um as an organization that has expertise
in the matter of mental health I just
wanted to ask if if there would be any
reason for concern
over calling to teach children
specifically skills to recognize
personal mental health issues in
themselves and peers
kind of sounds like maybe
self-diagnosing and diagnosing each
other and does that introduce any
possibility of um social contagion and
such
uh thank you for your question I don't
personally have any concerns regarding
that I know from my personal life a lot
of people who lived with mental illness
for a long time were not able to
recognize it and pursue treatment
because they didn't know what they were
going through uh I
if they have the tools to uh recognize
that and then pursue professional help
they would receive that professional
help thank you
forensic questions from the committee
represent cordelli
thank you thank you for being here
um to follow up on that uh
um phrase that we're just talking about
on line 19 recognizing personal mental
health issues
um
we have a chapter in statute about
suicide prevention education
and part of that includes education of
faculty and students and
um the
section related the paragraphs related
to student education includes warning
signs of mental disorders and suicide so
how is that that's already in statute
different than what we're talking about
here
uh thank you for your question I haven't
seen the statute so I can only speak to
it based off your question of course
mental health disorders go beyond
depression and suicide this includes a
more exhaustive list of what would be
covered
um
it is good for that reason
um other than that I can't really speak
to the Statue not having it in front of
me
further further questions from the
committee
not see any thank you very much thank
you uh next person is Anne-Marie
Banfield
thank you
chairman and honor honorable members of
the House Education committee for the
record my name is Anne-Marie Banfield
I'm a parental rights Advocate focused
on academic excellence and education
just making sure okay
um SB 151 would add mental health to the
definition of an adequate education
by the way I posed this while everyone
would agree that a good mental health
would be priority for all of us for our
students what exactly does this mean in
our schools for instance does it mean
that you have good mental health if you
are religious because there are studies
out there that would suggest that
spirituality and religious beliefs
contribute to good mental health
would that be included in the mental
health standards would it be excluded
from Nami mental health benefits of
religion religion gives people Something
to Believe In provides a sense of
structure and typically offers a group
of people to connect with over similar
beliefs
so there is a there is a component I
guess the question would be would that
be included in the standards or would
they be excluded
who will teach mental health in class A
teacher who has never been educated or
trained in the field of Mental Health
nothing in this law describes who is
qualified to teach children in the area
of Mental Health mental health addresses
serious issues like depression anxiety
and even suicide are they subjects left
up to those without a doctorate in child
psychology shouldn't you include the
credentials of someone
who is educated and clinically trained
in the field of child psychology
would you want a teacher covering the
subject of cancer in a public school
even the nurse school nurse wouldn't be
qualified to cover that subject
we have an illiteracy problem in our
schools and now there is an attempt to
shift more Focus away from mourning the
core academic subjects what will take
the place of mental health education in
our schools what will this be replaced
by will the Arts or Civics education be
eliminated or diluted again
there have been attempts to deal with
mental health of students in our public
schools and some of it has been a
literal disaster
I remind you of the deaf education that
was taught in Columbine High School
years ago where they thought that they
could help children who were struggling
with loved ones who had died
mental health education had children
writing their obituaries visiting the
local morgue to see dead people and
telling children about what it was like
after they died
when 2020 covered the story one of the
students talked about how she was led to
contemplate suicide
you can do Google death education 2020
in Columbine to watch the story it's
still on YouTube
several years ago in Indiana school
administrators administered mental
health screenings to students the mental
health screening tool was called teen
screen
one mother reported that her
fifteen-year-old daughter was physically
upset after taking the mental health
assessment
when her daughter came home she asked
her parents what OCD and social anxiety
disorder was the people at school told
her daughter that she was mentally ill
based on a computer test that took 10
minutes to answer
at that time no parent consented
consented to the assessment
parents the parents wanted to know why
their daughter was flagged for being
mentally ill here is what the parent
reported her daughter answered no when
she was asked if she went out a lot
this was what a question on on the
assessment the daughter answered no
because she wasn't allowed to go out on
school nights another question was do
you ever feel anxious or nervous when
you are in a with a group of your peers
she answered yes because she was she had
to get up in front of her class to give
a book report so she got nervous many
people come here before this committee
and are very nervous
but that doesn't make a mentally ill
why would a school district give
children their an assessment a screening
like this according to Harvard Medical
School and author of the truth about
drug companies by Marsha angel
it was just a way to put more people on
prescription drugs the pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical industry was behind the
teen screen
parents through the school district but
you can see how sometimes this process
can be corrupted and that can happen
when mental health screenings are
administered at school by people who
don't know who are not properly educated
or trained
and now we have the same thing happening
in our schools in New Hampshire mental
health data on New Hampshire students
are now shared with evaluators so they
can report back to the federal
government
Plymouth State Antioch University and
now Keen State have all had access to
mental health records on New Hampshire
students without informed consent by the
student or their parents this violates
basic mental health codes of ethics
when a parent takes their child to a
licensed child psychologist for an
assessment or treatment the child
psychologist must follow a strict code
of ethics that includes informed consent
before assessing trading or disclosing
the sensitive data
if a child enters a public school in New
Hampshire school counselors and school
social workers have made their
personally identifiable information
available to the staff of those
universities for reporting purposes
according to their own contracts with
the New Hampshire Schools they're asking
for the child's social security number
political affiliations
and religious beliefs just to name a few
it is shocking that many of those in the
mental health field are ignoring basic
guidelines but they are
it was finally finally to follow up or
to conclude it was before this commit
committee a few weeks ago that many of
you asked how Civics education was
narrowed down or even eliminated in some
of our schools maybe the answer lies
with the laws that are passed that Force
schools to eliminate instruction in the
core academic subjects
for these reasons I urge you to vote itl
on SB 151
um
one of the biggest contributors to the
mental health problem amongst teens in
in children in school was the school
shutdowns
I worked with parents across the state
trying begging pleading School
administrators to open up the schools
I worked with parents who were writing
to the commissioner and copying me about
serious mental health issues suicidal
attempts
by some of these kids
because the schools were shut down by
the individuals you want to put in
charge of their Mental Health
you know what works gym class
address bullying the things that you
guys have worked on a lot of that makes
it for a good environment within the
um
and finally I was talking to an
individual driving here about a book
that because books are so controversial
in schools right now there's a book in a
school and um
it's bad it's bad it's very dark
and
um talks about trauma kids that have
gone through trauma and and we both
agreed that if a child who's gone
through trauma reads this book
it's going to reignite trauma there are
things that are problems in these
schools right now and and and and so my
concern is you're asking people who are
not trained and educated clinically
trained in the field of child psychology
to once again delve into this topic I
thank you for listening thank you very
much other questions yes represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here and taking my
question you identified yourself as a
parental rights advocate so are you less
opposed to this bill after it came out
of the Senate with the amendment
beginning on line 24 which
clarifies that parents have the right to
object to the material
I do I think certainly it's it's a it's
a Improvement
um I talked to the Senators and I had
and when this was in committee
um
certainly any time that you can make
something transparent it helps but I
think you know I think either
representative Ladd when he was first
questioning Senator Waters brought up
some excellent points representative you
brought up some excellent points I think
that this is such a big issue and please
understand that I think that mental
health amongst our kids is extremely
important but I've seen the bad side too
I've seen you know the problems that
come from good intention teachers or
individuals working in the schools
who do not have that expertise and I do
work with PhD level child psychologists
and I learn from them and I know the
dangers because a lot of them get the
kids out of the school and into their
private practice to help these kids who
who dealt with trauma so you bring up
trauma in class you know you never know
where this conversation is going to go
in a classroom if you if you say Okay
teacher I want you to teach mental
health you don't know what kind of
subjects are going to come up what you
know are you going to Define that for a
teacher and you're going to say you have
to strict to state to the script and and
suicide comes up or something traumatic
comes up where does that discussion go
it's it's very difficult I know I
probably rambled on about that yeah I do
think that that improved it sorry
further questions
yes represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony I'm just
curious because
it seems like over the years through
education we've we've tried to implement
various programs over different periods
of time are you aware of any Trends as
far as tracking students mental health
as we have implemented programs that
attempt to address these issues such as
social emotional learning and other
things and how that trend line over time
has affected students
um what do you mean by tracking as far
as
um it basically has mental health gotten
better worse stayed the same over time
I don't know that answer I don't know I
think you would have to look at
independent peer-reviewed studies to get
that information I think sometimes we I
think especially in education sorry but
there's a lot of information that's
brought that's not peer-reviewed or
independent and so as as legislators I
would caution you I caution everybody
and I think in the field of medicine
it's always going to be peer-reviewed
and independent but a lot of times what
comes into education is not peer
reviewed it's not independent so for
instance the report that has to go back
to the federal government on on the
mtssb program that's in the school right
now that's our peer-reviewed that's not
independent it looks more like a sales
brochure on the mtssb program and yet
um all that data that's coming in to to
these evaluators
parents don't know that their child's
mental health has been shared with with
these individuals
um so you know I see so many problems
already that I you know unless again
this is specifically defined and you you
you go through this and you you want to
add things it's got to be well defined
who gets to teach this
um you know because these subjects are
going to come up you know somebody you
know representative Luna brought up um
Eating Disorders I can tell you that
that there are girls that you just bring
up that subject it plants a seed oh I
need to lose weight
oh I can go make myself throw up in the
bathroom and lose weight I mean we had
the survey years ago that asked kids on
these surveys
did
did you or have you ever sniffed glue to
get high guess what all these kids were
learning now that they get to get high
from sniffing glue off of a survey so
you you you teach what you're trying to
do to help can oftentimes backfire and
that's my concern thank you I don't know
if that answered your question sorry
about that
further questions from the committee yes
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I actually have two
um as a preface I spent a 40 40-year
career as a dietitian specializing in
I don't know how to say this as a
question so I'm just going to state that
it is not factual that talking about
eating disorders creates them
my second part is a question
are you aware that it is widely
acknowledged that not talking about
suicide increases the risk of suicide
I I'm not aware of that particular but
again who's talking about it in this
instance I would be you're talking about
a teacher so and what is what's the
conversation because if you go back and
you look at Columbine they were talking
about that and then it led that student
to to then contemplate suicide I mean
that that was the that was a fact so I
don't know that's your conclusion that
that was perfect that's not a known fact
I do have one more question and I'm just
going to parallel the question to my
experience as a elementary school
teacher at Elementary School principal
and administrator uh over the years in
Maine in Alaska
I observed that one of the trends that
we had back then was ADD ADHD
and teachers when they heard about ADHD
this kid's hyper so we got to throw
another pill in them is this the type of
activity that could could come about if
we don't have these people that are
dealing and trying to deal with a
curriculum dealing with mental health
could we have another
you know direction that we're having uh
information conveyed to Children which
maybe needed to be done through a school
psychologist rather than and parent
rather than through the teacher in a
classroom I'm a little bit concerned of
where we're going with this that's
exactly when you were speaking earlier
that's exactly what my concern was
because
it's not that you know I'm opposed to
helping a child with their mental health
I think we can all I know everybody on
this committee is concerned about that
it's more about who we're putting in
charge and and I do work with PhD level
child psychologists I don't comment this
with just me I look at what they are
saying what they are telling me and
and you're absolutely right I mean I
wouldn't put myself in front of a child
and and even with some training and
think that I can do what they can do so
yes I I mean I think that there's a
there's a reason why they are clinically
trained there's a reason why they have a
code of ethics uh if they if they if
they don't follow their code of ethics
you know as a parent I can go and I can
ask for their license to be removed I
can go to licensing board
um how do you deal with somebody who's
going in that direction in a classroom
that may put a child in danger and it's
happened we have examples where this has
happened so it's not like something you
know that I'm making up it we we have
examples of where that has happened
um you know you hope that that's not
going to happen and you in you and I do
believe that most of these teachers have
their best interest at heart but I can
have their best interests at heart but I
can tell you that I don't know what a
child psychologist knows
thank you further questions thank you
very much
foreign
House Education committee thank you so
much for having me here today
my name is Laura Lee Godfrey and I am 18
years old from Portsmouth New Hampshire
I am the chair of the governor's youth
advisory Council on substance misuse and
prevention our Council advises the
governor on New Hampshire's opioid
crisis from a youth perspective after
collaborating with my peers on this
Council I helped author this legislation
with Senator Waters to address a
pressing need within New Hampshire and
I'm here today to ask you to vote ought
to pass with Amendment on SB 151
so last winter my best friend had her
first panic attack while I was driving
in the car with her I immediately pulled
over to the side of the road neither of
us had any experience dealing with a
panic attack before and as I clutched
her hand I frantically tapped out a
Google search to help her and I did tell
my best friend that I wasn't ignoring
her through her panic attack but instead
looking up how to help her
my friend is just one of many teenagers
undergoing what's been called a mental
health crisis in the United States
countless young adults face
deteriorating mental health in the midst
of neurodivergence conflict or high
familial or academic demands and all my
friends have struggled in one way or
another bottling mental health issues
that they don't know how to respond to
and they simply lack the knowledge on
how to take care of themselves
as a New Hampshire student I've never
once been taught how to take care of my
mental health and in a situation where
my best friend needed my help I did not
know how to help her
I posed this question to my peers from
across the state in the governor's
Council and across a range of public
private and Charter Schools few of us
actually underwent mental health
education
our students met with Governor sununa
where we mutually agreed this issue
needed to be addressed like us Governor
sununu is concerned about mental health
in New Hampshire and he encouraged us to
write a report summarizing our findings
I emailed that reports the committee
this morning and I also have passed
around several physical copies as well
and our recommendations concluded that
legislative action was necessary
right now New Hampshire's only inclusion
of mental health education is in
recommended guidelines from 2007. they
are not required they're outdated and
they're simply not being taught to
students that needs to change
sp-151 can improve this
if we look to other states like Illinois
in Prior New Hampshire legislation
similar educational initiatives have
been tackled without infringing upon
municipalities when drafting this
legislation our Council specifically
worked as to not pass an unfunded
mandate to our schools and to our
teachers
in this legislation the Department of
Education can Define mental health as a
characteristic of an essential education
and write model curriculum for school
implementation with the doe support in
establishing clear-cut competencies
lesson plans and resources schools will
already have the tools they need to
engage students
the Senate amendment to SB 151fn
eliminates the findings which is
non-essential to the intents of this
legislation and it also reinforces that
parents can opt out of this instruction
for their children as is the case in
existing statute and I am in strong
support of this amendment
now this policy isn't a Panacea it's not
the Silver Bullet that's going to end
mental health disorders as we know them
updating these standards from 2007 to
2023 will should stat students on the
path to being better prepared citizens
and leaders by empowering youth through
education and resource accessibility New
Hampshire can prevent slides in the
substance misuse and break the stigma
around Mental Health
our state can do its part to keep youth
safe and healthy
if this policy can help just one girl
pulled over to the side of the road with
her own or with her friends mental
health it'll be worth it
thank you for your consideration and I
humbly ask you about ought to pass with
Amendment on SB 151 I will take any
questions thank you very much questions
represent paternal
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
presenting this legislation it's quite a
daunting task I appreciate it I have a
question as a high school student what
you must have a vision of what this
education would look like
and
I'll start there
yes absolutely thank you so much for
your question so as outlined in our
health education report we do have a
vision of certain aspects that we want
taught mainly certain types of mental
disorders that aren't currently taught
as well as mental health coming
strategies but there are more specifics
in the report that I emailed to you
go ahead how early
um in your education do you think this
curriculum would begin
I think sooner rather than later but
definitely should be an essential part
of a high school education for sure
further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you
like that
interesting
good morning my name is Emma savini I am
the children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a non-partisan non-profit
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates for the health and wellness
of all Granite Staters we are here in
strong support of house Senate Bill 151
today because it would emphasize the
importance of mental health through
Youth and teach them basic tools and
techniques that could help reduce the
stressors they face in their everyday
lives
as you just heard so eloquently put by
this the young woman who assisted
drafting this bill teens are facing a
mental health crisis and they don't
really know what to do in certain
circumstances
having this is a part of an adequate
education we give them those tools to
adequately address
those emergent circumstances that pop up
when you're driving in a car when you're
walking between class and it also will
give students the ability to have an
open conversation with trusted adults in
their lifetime in their life to reach
out for help so that they can be
connected with those mental health
professionals to provide treatment when
that's appropriate I want to be so clear
this bill is not asking teachers to
provide mental health treatment to
students this is simply asking that
teachers provide students with education
about what mental health is and give
them the tools to adequately address the
stressors in their life
by giving them the tools to either reach
out for further treatment from a mental
health provider or by giving them the
coping strategies they can use in a
day-to-day life just like deep breathing
techniques or something similar
as we've heard this bill would
um give the Department of Education the
ability to change its rules to better
address what this looks like and so any
um
specifics that may not be addressed in
this legislature could be addressed in
those rules for instance who is teaching
this curriculum and those types of
questions
um
finally new features supports this
because children's Behavioral Health
isn't a severe crisis right now students
across our state are suffering as
evidenced by the most recent yrbs data
mental health concerns are increasing or
at least staying the same anything we
can do to help give our students the
tools to help reduce those concerns and
issues they're facing is a step in the
right direction and so I ask that you
vote Senate Bill 151 ought to pass and
I'm happy to answer any questions thank
you very much other questions yes
representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question I like
the way that you separated you know what
might happen in schools versus actual
therapy and and you know in-depth
treatment and I was wondering if um you
see that the school's role is more is
teaching Mental Health First Aid
I'm sorry I didn't catch what the last
phrase Mental Health First Aid oh
um I I think that school should
absolutely consider teaching that as
well and I think it is a program that um
it's been shown to work and is really
beneficial to the students who have
taken it
um so I'd be more than open to having
encouraging schools to provide that
instruction to their students as well
I do have one question
um the the uh adding of this into the
adequacy formula it says mental health
education
and there's rules which develop a
curriculum
but I also see a timeline in which this
goes in effect 60 days after signage is
that enough time for teachers to be
properly prepared
and what they should teach where the
line is where I'm doing the first aid
aspect of this or where I'm getting into
the psychologist aspects of it
is realistic that we put this in place
immediately
thank you so much for your question I'm
not an expert on how information is
disseminated to teachers in school
districts so that may be a better asked
by some to someone from the Department
of Education or school districts thank
you thank you further questions just
representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for for
answering these questions
uh
where's the role of of parents in the
middle of teaching and recognizing and
bringing in resources
absolutely thank you so much for your
question that's a really great Point
um as we've seen with other initiatives
in schools that involve teachers and
parents working cohesively outcomes are
exponentially better for instance with
the mtssb program that program
emphasizes uh parents working with the
schools in tandem to incorporate
Behavioral Health supports both in
school and at home that program is
evidence-based and has been shown to be
extremely effective in providing better
Behavioral Health outcomes both in
schools and at home so we know that that
works I think that this bill does not
prohibit that by any stretch prohibit
parents from being involved and I think
most schools would actually encourage
parents to work with their teacher their
students teachers or the school
administration to
you know learn what their students are
learning and also help you know
incorporate those coping strategies or
Behavioral Health supports at the their
home as well
yes
uh the multi-tiered system of supports
for Behavioral Health
a tiered structure framework that is
implemented in some schools in New
Hampshire it's again an evidence-based
program and it provides some level of
Behavioral Health supports to all
students you know in the anti-bullying
campaign or helping to include improved
School climate and then for students who
need higher levels of support the levels
of support goes up and it's fewer
students naturally as you go up the
chain for what level of support they
need but at all levels parents are
involved and aware that this is going on
further questions
thank you very much thank you
good morning Melissa white New Hampshire
Department of Education division of
learner support director and I'm
available to answer any questions you
might have okay I do have one for you
then if we're going to be talking doe
now great
um this is an area we're putting this
bill in wood in 193 E2 which is
identifies excuse me the criteria that
make up the the learning areas of study
but there it's also supposed to be
replicated again we've seen this
disconnect when we saw another bill come
in from the Department where it's
mentioned here but it's not mentioned in
193 E2
uh or E3 where we have the
accountability for the delivery of this
and so how would the department uh
because all areas of adequacy require
accountability and I don't see this
referencing that section of law at all
uh how are we going to have an
accountability model built in on this
so the
component of this that becomes also
challenging is that the you know we look
further down into 193 E2
um Roman numeral five the Department of
Education and the State Board of
Education
Institute the procedures for maintaining
updating improving and refining the
minimum standards for public school
approval
however the curriculum each School
District shall be responsible for
maintaining updating improving and
refining curriculum
so that's the piece where we it becomes
a little bit challenging because this
state specifically the department shall
adopt rules regarding the provision of
mental health curriculum so we're
running into
one statute that's saying curriculum
lives with the local level
but then this is stating it lives with
the Department of Education
so I think that's a piece that we might
want to just clarify the Department of
Education could
um you know do an RFP procure the
um the curriculum specified on Mental
Health
and so we could run that we could
purchase the curriculum we could make
that curriculum available
across the state to all of our local
education agencies agencies schools and
all of the chartered Public Schools we
can make that available and do that
portion of it but as far as the
accountability piece for ensuring that
it has been the curriculum is
implemented in the school that would not
fall under the department of education's
ability
well then I'll follow that up because
all areas of adequacy which we have in
193 E2 appear also in in the section
accountability for the opportunity for
an adequate education 193 e3b and it
lists all those areas now we have a
little disconnect because some of them
we've changed and hasn't been reflected
that was caught by 266 and we're being
asked to rewrite that also but it
appears to me if we're going to be
putting this in underneath adequacy
where the criteria is listed and not
putting it in the other area we're going
to get in the same boat we are with 266
okay so that needs to be looked up as
well then
represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair so um I
just want to you know sort of be clear
on what uh what you were just um
referring to Ms White so looking on line
continuing from line 12. rule making on
the provision of mental health
curriculum it doesn't say development of
mental health curriculum so so wouldn't
wouldn't that read on provision which
would mean for public schools to to
provide
um uh mental health curriculum as
identified in paragraph one and uh
including all the things that are that
are listed below and wouldn't that
provision also have accountability uh uh
I
so I I don't I I don't see this as as
requiring the department to develop a
curriculum certainly not in 60 days
um
but make sure that that school districts
are following rules to provide said
curriculum
see what I'm saying so I'm looking at 24
and it says the Department of Education
shall make available electronically
model curriculum on mental health
education so I think that's the piece I
was where were you looking line number
24 number five where it states the
Department of Education shall make
available electronically model
curriculum mental health education
mind learning all right sir
all right let's not be in the amendment
I'm sorry I'm sorry section four right
right
right and oh I apologize I was looking
at the introduced I wasn't looking at
so school districts shall make
curriculum course materials available
so that piece of it I thought was about
the objectionable
material but that's replacing section
section five I believe is the prime
sponsors that is the is the the right of
a parent to opt out of curriculum and
and basically extends that to to this
curriculum but uh but I don't see any
requirement in here unless you're you're
seeing it in any version of this bill
that requires the State Board to develop
curriculum that you do think that was
the previous she'll make available
electric electronically model curriculum
as the department does in so many areas
right now yes and we could make that
available we just couldn't require them
to it right right
are there further questions yes
representative cascadden thank you Mr
chair thank you Melissa for being here
um
parts of this on 20 says that the
department is going to make available an
electronic model curriculum
so do you ever see that a teacher in a
classroom
could assign that as a homework so that
it's done at home or and then they can
check the box that they've done it or
will the department have to hire someone
to kind of
you know go out in the field and figure
this out
I'm not sure how it would like I'm not
sure how the local level would implement
it and then
that would be an option based on this do
you think
I don't know I mean you don't have to
have it's not a right answer I'm looking
to see well what you know
what can a classroom teacher do
if they are now mandated to provide this
instruction that would be determined at
the local level
how it's done well it has to be done
according to the RSA yes okay according
to the I'm sorry the people's
legislation yes
all right thanks
but this does say that Doe make
available electronic model curriculum so
how much is that going to cost you as a
department to make a model for
curriculum so we would run an RFP to uh
accept in those proposals and then of
course score them based on that when we
use the 100 000 estimate that's based on
an average across the board that we look
at model curriculums if we're purchasing
a curriculum for any type of content
area so it can range you know from you
know ten thousand dollars to the
millions and so when we kind of average
in uh purchases of curriculum to
implement Statewide our average is
around somewhere in the middle we got
trying to try to choose a hundred
thousand it is usually around there um
for example a
um stem Career and Technical education
learningblade online platform that we
implemented that was uh at the cost of a
one hundred thousand dollars how much
was that one hundred thousand dollars so
that we kind of looks there's some that
we were looking particularly when we
were analyzing the dyslexia screening
some of those screening on some of those
curriculums were running you know up to
eight hundred thousand dollars so there
is you know a variance but we would
definitely go through that um
procurement process of running that RFP
and then taking in those proposals and
up scoring and of course being prudent
with
and when would you have all this
completed
so
Steve days I don't know if we could have
it implemented quite that because we do
have
do Hangout to be over ten thousand
dollars we would have to go through
Governor Council and go through the
process so it would be a tight
turnaround but we we could we could do
that
I I don't know if the schools could
implement it in 60 days that's the piece
of it that I don't think is possible for
example if we look at the changes that
we made recently
um with the uh legislation that
implemented the Civics education
assessment and having to take the
naturalization test and all of the um
collection of data and all that piece of
IT schools were able to implement that
it took over a year so they're looking
at implementing this year but that
passed a year ago
so that's an example of to implement new
curriculum usually it takes about
representative
do you know if there exists now model
legislation that's out there that is
free that the doe the curriculum I'm
sorry that the doe could just put
pointers to to say there's this uh and
this and this you know if there are
multiple things and let the school
districts then choose
sure I mean we could research all of the
free materials that are available out
there and then just provide links so
that schools are aware of what those
could be and they could access them if
they needed to we could do that so and
that would cut down that hundred
thousand correct but if we were yes
purchasing a curriculum to implement
Statewide
um I think that's the piece of it that
we'd have to actually pay for it I think
vendors are careful about so much free
how much of their free material they
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here to take these questions
um I just wanted to clarify a little bit
of testimony we heard earlier in your
opinion on it
um starting with line 12 under C here
um we heard uh some testimony earlier
that the items listed would be optional
for what the department chose to adopt
but it seems to me that the use of the
word shall adopt and in consideration of
the following
it seems to me that that could be
reasonably interpreted to mean it needs
to include these things would that be a
reasonable way that you might interpret
including a consideration of the
following
do I have the correct language I believe
in my opinion including a consideration
of the following
seems
vague
fear it's a consideration of
we could look at it and then just not
included or take that to mean yes it has
to be included so I guess it's
that's exactly what I was interested in
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh for
taking my question
so are we looking at a Statewide
curriculum that every school should be
using and how would we incorporate
different grades if it's a curriculum my
understanding the proposed legislation
is looking at adding mental health to
the adequate public education components
so there's like that that piece of it
and then there's another piece of it
that's looking specifically at
the making available that electronic
making the electronically available
curriculum to uh
there's nothing saying the schools have
to use that curriculum it's just saying
that the department would have to make
follow up yes so the schools wouldn't
have to okay but schools would have to
adopt something
I would think so yes
adequate
for example I know that with health and
wellness currently
um
oftentimes they'll have like a separate
at least at the elementary level where
my kids are at
um they'll have a wellness period so
they have their PE class and then
there's also a wellness class that they
take once a week and then a lot of the
um
components or content pieces for that
Wellness is delivered during that time
so they learn about taking care of
themselves hygiene that type of thing so
I
Health wellness and then mental health
kind of into that category so I guess
schools could
deliver it
and deliver that the uh content or the
the learning curriculum around the
learning components around that
particular you know with their own
chosen curriculum during those blocks
but I mean this would be up to the local
Education Agency to decide how they want
to deliver it how they want to meet the
requirements
so I I have one last question for you
um I'm concerned about the professional
development of ensuring that our
teachers are well prepared to venture
into this domain
and if you develop a
a framework or a guideline through this
electronic type version
um wouldn't it be best as to do what we
did with the math learning communities
where we worked with the community
college system New Hampshire to have
summer training for folks from the
school districts come down become
qualified to teach understand ask the
questions and then go back to the
classroom and with there's also support
coming from the community college to
ensure that if there's questions while
they're in the classroom they have that
resource to call I'm I'm real concerned
that we're going to have an
implementation date here we're going to
throw something at and the teacher is
going to be said teach this
and I as a teacher would be very leery
about where that line is and what I can
do what I can't do we've had that
question asked of us in other areas in
the classroom just recently our old
version of that but we all know where
I'm driving home there so I just don't
want to create something that's going to
cause another real significant issue
unless we have good strong professional
development available for our staff our
teachers correct and then would the Lea
be responsible for paying for that
professional development for their
teachers or would that be I don't know
it doesn't say within the bill here and
there's not yeah and you folks said you
couldn't determine other than maybe the
preparation that developed the
electronic version
so there's no mention of training at all
within this which is a concern to me
and if we implemented a training which
could be of course done there just would
be the cost associated with that and
that's going to be more than the 100 000
yeah that's just an issue to we all have
to think about here
further yes representative Tanner
yeah
um a couple of I I have a couple of
issues uh one is that as a former health
teacher
um if I were to get this uh and look at
it and say that I had to teach about
anxiety depression panic attacks of
cells you know etc etc
um
it's not the way
uh it's not the way I would do it and it
seems it seems
um
almost counterproductive to do that it's
like an old adage in the first aid and
EMT world where they had an ambulance
that came to the bottom of a cliff
repeatedly to pick up people that had
fallen over the cliff and then finally
somebody decided that maybe somebody
should go to the top of the cliff and
put a fence so people don't go over the
cliff
Stress Management most of these
disorders or most of the panic attack
that with a child had talked about
before
our result of the tremendous stress that
kids are under this these days
excuse me and I think that
to try to itemize things like this
rather than talk about the actual cause
and to talk about
presenting skills to students to deal
with the stress that they get whether
it's anxiety over a test or a panic
attack that they you know are are
experiencing because of a relationship
um that having those skills are really
more important than them knowing what an
obsessive compulsive person looks like
or what they actually do so
and and certainly as I talked about
before Mental Health First Aid Nami has
a great program that's available that I
think every teacher should have to take
and I'm the last person that likes to
require things like that but I also
think that we need to look at that
section and really look at
um like I said Stress Management and how
how to give kids the skills to deal with
the stress that they have so that it
doesn't develop into a lot of these
mental health issues already so I I know
that's not a question but I would like
to see the state
um you know look at that and and
certainly I think that's one thing when
we look at this bill that I will offer
as well
so thank you representative luno you had
well yeah thank you thank you very much
Mr chair so um it sort of it it
occurrency as we're sort of having this
uh this hearing and this conversation
that that we're looking at the text of
the of the bill is amended in the Senate
um without the context of the uh the law
that it seeks to amend so so
um I I guess
wouldn't some of the concerns that that
have been expressed by members around
the table here with respect to things
like professional development and who's
creating the curriculum and and all
these things potentially be uh be
covered in the um
the paragraph the or the the section of
the law that um that
Section 3 amends
and and what what this what the Bill's
doing is is adding to paragraph five
apparel a sub paragraph C but there's
also a sub paragraph b and a sub
paragraph a and five a
talks about developing curriculum 5A
talks about making sure that that
teachers are following following State
instructional standards and curriculum
standards and are prepared to um to
provide
um such instruction so that students and
it goes on to to talk about that so I
guess I'm trying to figure out what am I
missing here yes correct so it would
state that it does state that each
School District shall be responsible for
maintaining updating improving and
refining curriculum the curriculum shop
present educational goals broad
pedagogical approaches and strategies
for assisting students in the
development of the skills competencies
and knowledge called for by the minimum
standards for public school approval for
each area of Education identified in
paragraph one it is the responsibility
then of local teachers administrators
and school boards to identify and
Implement approaches best suited for the
students in their communities to acquire
skills and knowledge in the curriculum
to determine the scope organization
sequence of offerings and to choose the
methods of instruction activities and
materials to be used so I my
understanding that it would be a
the local level to provide that
professional development to the teachers
great thank you once the minimum
standards have been approved by the
State Board of Education
correct
and and Mr chair yeah and and as it
pertains and you know I don't mean to
get us off the rails here but the 60
days
that applies to the shells that are in
here the department shall adopt rules
the department shall make available
um uh School District's ship required to
adopt a policy
um
I mean that's where the Law changes is
well that that's that time frame we have
for science is just uh in the fact that
it's not going to work uh we when you're
talking about having to deal with gel
car you're having to develop those rules
on on the department and get those
things approved by you know is sent from
the state board to the gel car
uh is
right it doesn't say that the rules have
to be approved it's just 60 days that
that the law comes in I mean yeah I know
we're getting it what we would do to an
exact session here
but but there's a lot to this that you
know it's going to take a lot of good
discussion here and we could begin all
of the work most definitely within 60
days of the passage begin the work yeah
thank you very much uh anything else
from the committee yes representative
Ford thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I wonder I haven't
heard you mention and so I wonder if
you've
experience
excuse me I wonder if you've experienced
any of those
I'll call them social situations
that sometimes evolve around this kind
of a subject when it's being explored I
speak from some experience unpleasant
experiments about this kind of session
when you raise the question of human
sexuality
there's a lot of feedback that you
sometimes get the one that comes to mind
to me was when a young woman approached
me and said
please make my boyfriend quit beating me
and when you start talking about sexual
relations
those kinds of things will start coming
up and speaking of Representative caps
cadden and the teacher being approached
what happens when the little girl comes
up and says please make my daddy quit
beating my mother
how are you taught in student teaching
how to answer that question
I know when he came to me I was the
first lieutenant in it well it's me
and I went for help and organized a
completely
invasive approach the person truck you
know had him job trained all that kind
of stuff
it wasn't enough
and those things will arise
and they will be stimulated by these
kinds of discussions which are part of
the subject
got a question
did she uh
did she have any experience or any
occasion to think about those concerns
as well
she's coming from the department and
giving us technical advice
uh on on the bill and how they would do
this yes as a teacher the I mean your
required reporter so if anything is
revealed to you as a teacher you're
required to write well I was
sympathizing with representative
cascadden and our teacher I'll come to
what happens when that teacher how do
in my personal experience as a teacher
as it also required reporting so when
anything you're presented with you
report it you get your administrator
involved you also employ the experts
around you which tend to be the child
psychologists
or the um
uh school counselor to help with next
steps in addressing
those specific issues but there's one
thing I want to I'd like to just make a
parallel to if possible
that a lot of the
um content area
mention here is really mirrors a lot of
the work that's being done with mtssb
and there's a lot of requirements in
empty in our you know our legislation
around mtssb and so a lot of the work
being done in our schools with those
multi-tiered systems of support for
Behavior will look specifically at what
is appropriate to do school-wide
perhaps you know
teaching all students about
obsessive-compulsive disorder is not a
tier one or an all-school level
um specific area to look at but maybe
it's something more tier two the
education around so there's there's
different pieces that I think are
there's some overlap here with work that
we're already doing
um through mtssb and a lot of the other
initiatives and our wellness program
and through the work that we coordinate
with Department of Health and Human
Services so there is a lot of overlap
further questions of the department
we have no further pink cards on this so
I'm going to close this hearing for
Senate Bill 151 thank you for the
committee we're right on the lunch hour
here and we're planning on having a
caucus in between doing our exact
sessions which will follow here so what
foreign okay I think we're ready to go
ahead here for our exact sessions we're
just going to go through it by the
numbers so we'll start with 24 and work
okay uh we have in front of us SB 24
relative to conferring degree granting
authority to the New England
aeronautical institution
um what we're going to do on that is
we're going to
uh hold off on that we want to have
further information provided to us by
and namely that's involves like Jim Dean
and uh it would also involve Mark
Rubinstein
it's authorizing you know the New
England aeronautical institution to do
business here in the state but uh more
information is needed
so
so we're going to jump over that bill
and and go to the next bill
uh 25 and I Look to representative
cordelli for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I would move to
a motion made by representative
cardellion second by representative Ford
discussion representative cordelli uh
thank you
um we had already passed uh House Bill
71 which is the same bill that is in the
Senate
um the senate committee was uh favorable
to that I think it was a five-nothing
vote the full Senate hasn't
um hasn't voted on that yet so my
thought is that we should retain this in
not seeing any Madam clerk would you
is Chairman cordelli yes
representative yes representative Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonnell yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes
20 years 0 and 8th
alrighty next one 39 SP 39 relative to
criminal history checks for school
transportation monitors
love to represent Parnell for a motion
please I move ought to pass on Senate
Bill 39th
is there a second
second
okay we have a motion to ought to pass
by made by representative and second by
representative cordelli uh
representative do you have any
discussion yes this bill was a request
from the Department of Education it
removes Transportation monitors from the
purview of the Department of Education
for the purposes of criminal records
checks Transportation monitors do not
actually drive the buses but they
directly assist with the students which
puts their oversight under the SAU
School District chartered public school
or public Academy to provide services
further discussion
representative Luna thank you very much
Mr chair so um so I'm you know I think
prepared to support the um the ought to
pass but I think um there has been some
some uh discussion that that this could
cause some confusion or problems with
with some school districts and I was
wondering if if um if the if Ms Wilson
might might be able to
um
she's hiding behind that little box in
front of me this is on um on House Bill
39 criminal history record
afternoon for the record Becky Wilson uh
New Hampshire school boards Association
how can I help answer the questions
I'm just wondering if there's if um if
there are concerns out there that there
could be some consequences that come out
of this bill that may create some maybe
problematic for some districts
thank you for the question or the
clarification I I will say I think that
um you know some of these questions are
probably best directed to the department
in terms of how what the current
practices are however the transportation
monitors as representative penernal
mentioned are typically on
transportation for some students in in
particular as an IEP service that's part
of a child's IEP Transportation
monitoring to ensure safety of students
we have some students who are non-verbal
for example or students who just need
additional oversight during a longer
trip it's not uncommon for
transportation monitors to be on Regular
Ad buses but also on special education
Transportation so the the challenges I
think with this is that a lot of
Transportation that's going to an out of
District placement for example they may
pick up students from multiple districts
to go to the same placement
um it's not if it's a transportation
monitor who is employed by the school
district and monitoring a School
District school-owned transportation
going to and from a local public school
for example that that is fairly easy to
figure out who's doing the background
check is the SAU or the superintendent
um for the background checks for
transportation monitors who might be
employed by a contracted service
provider
um that how those background checks are
done is something that's negotiated
between the SAU and the contracted
provider so you all the contractor
providers to my knowledge and again I'm
not a contracted service provider but do
their own background checks on the
transportation monitor some school
districts have in their contract with
that company that they are also going to
do their own background check
some do not necessarily do it back a
second background check they are relying
on the transportation provider to do
that
um
there's some you know liability I think
no matter which way you go with that but
if you have multiple students from
different districts riding on One
Transportation with one monitor there's
a potential that if you had four or five
six kids from different districts on one
bus that is a contracted provider that
that monitor is going to be background
checked six or seven times
I don't know
how you resolve if one District says we
are okay with what's on the background
check you know obviously there's some
things that you can't ignore the section
5 violations for example are not
negotiable but as is often said in this
commit committee employment decisions
based on the background check are at the
level of the district so if you have
multiple districts with students on that
bus and multiple districts are doing
background checks for the same person
I just
at what you know I don't know at what
point
that causes a potential challenge
um
I think there's it's just not consistent
necessarily who is doing the background
check for contracted providers or
whether you want that somehow in a
contract if you are a district that's
Contracting with multiple
so just a quick follow-up so so if um if
one of the school districts let's say
with multiple school districts one of
the school districts conducted the the
background check and then the
superintendents talked and said Yep this
this person's clear they could all agree
that or if they wanted to they could
agree or could they agree to to go with
that one background check or if they all
wanted to do independent background
checks could they go ahead and do that
as well well thank you for the question
I think the challenge would come from
the statutes you already have about
background checks that only the
superintendent and their designee are
able to
view the background check and then
communicate with others so six six
superintendents couldn't look at the
same background check they would have to
do their own individual background
representative woodcock
thank you uh Mr chair I don't know if
this is for Miss Wilson or president of
pertinel I don't know which one but my
question is is the Transportation uh
monitor background check that's done by
the bus company
uh similar in quality to the
transportation check done by the school
thank you for the question I don't know
that I can answer that I'm not
I think it I don't know what the
transportation companies
requirements are I I believe and I'm
speaking a bit out of turn because I'm
not the one that's signing any of these
contracts but my belief would be that if
you have a district as part of their
contract with these outside companies is
accepting that background check that
there it must meet a certain criteria
for the person to be able to be to sign
that contract but I don't know offhand
what I would imagine so
um I think the original intention of
this bill was just to get it out of the
Department of Safety and put it back to
the district which I think I understand
the Catalyst for that
um I I just think it wouldn't we
districts would like it to be clear
about what it is that they're supposed
to do in these situations where they're
using a contracted provider
sure just a comment to the chair of
Primrose I um and I wasn't here for I
saw someone on screen on the you know
the home but my concern is that the the
last year we had uh the last two
sessions Rick we had questions about uh
private private coach Vehicles those bus
drivers in and I understand why that
passed uh in the background check stuff
but this concerns me that we're going
once again moving into a uh process of
less evaluation versus equal to one more
so everybody confused I know I'm so
sorry I apologize for confusing everyone
foreign
it is a bit different than bus drivers
yeah
um because the drivers obviously are
falling under the department of Ed which
I think everyone to my knowledge is
comfortable with that because those are
somewhat portable
um the transportation monitors are
typically I don't want to say specific
to an individual student but to some
extent specific to certain
employment issue to the district it's an
employment
consideration I guess for lack of a
better term yes yeah I think uh I think
uh attorney Fenton did indicate that
there could be an mou that could be
developed between school districts
uh dealing with respective monitors that
may be dealing with kids in multiple
school districts multiple School
situations
hmm
does anybody more time on this bill
or are you
ready to go ahead with it so yeah just a
clarifying uh question but so
representative Miler
um uh recalls that um that the attorney
from the Department said that that
multiple districts may be able to end
enter into a memorandum of understanding
uh with respect to um uh Transportation
monitor maybe saying that district one
takes care of doing the hiring and
background check and if if that um
all works out then the the other
districts will defer to that as opposed
to sharing background check information
which they they cannot do under under
current law
um and and that in the worst case it
sounds like the employee the prospective
employee would be background checked if
it was if it was four districts possibly
four times which cumbersome
um doesn't
um
it doesn't break the system it doesn't
mean that now children are students are
going to be transported uh in a
situation where where a transportation
monitor is necessary that where they
can't hire a I mean it doesn't prevent a
monitor from being hired
um thanks for the question I think I I
think I would defer any legal background
check questions to the department and I
would ask I guess that those questions
go to attorney Fenton she really is the
criminal background check person in
terms of the interplay of all of that
and how an mou would work
um and what happens if districts don't
agree on the monitor or which whatever
however that would play out okay thanks
Becky you're welcome
as represent Cornell is this going to
finance after us
no no no this is a bill we don't have to
necessarily act on today either
um we've we've written mous in the
various forms of legislation in the past
I remember we wrote an mou between
Dartmouth College and the Hanover Police
Department
dealing with uh rape on campus
that was years ago so we we've been in
the business of adding mou language into
bills if that's something which might
help clarify here
um
but there's no necessary urgency to be
doing something today
we have
well then if there's really a feeling if
there's no sense not doing anything if
we're not going to do anything on the
side otherwise we'll just go ahead but
if we're going to look for something to
try and
clear up some of the ambiguity maybe
it's wise doing that
if it's going to help a school district
i i as a monitor I wouldn't want to have
to go get four or five different checks
that's that's craziness if an mou could
be written where you know I do it with
your district and then the other four
districts over there are accepting it
why isn't that good yeah right but saves
I I I agree with you I don't think that
necessarily we have to put it into the
statute that there's going to be an mou
then why do we need to build
move it to move the background check out
take a vote how about just a show of
hands how many people would like to just
take a vote and get this thing done
today or how many people
okay I guess we're all there
okay so let's move on with it then
so is there any further discussion on on
the bill right now we're on SB 39 the
motion on the table is ought to pass any
further discussion on that motion
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll then
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
yes representative yes representative
Myler yeah representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yeah
representative Wilcox
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni
yes
representative cascaden
ah yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years one day
all right with consent yes
okay
the next bill is SBE 77 relative to
changes in school placement for students
representative cardellier recognized for
emotion uh thank you uh I would like to
move ought to pass on House Bill excuse
me Senate Bill 77
is there a second
represent Lucas makes a second so we
have a motion on the table ought to pass
on SB 77 made by representative cordelli
and second by representative leckis
representative cordelli do you have any
discussion
uh thank you
um I believe that in our statute for
best interest in manifest education
hardship
throughout this uh section of law it
refers to an approved private schools or
public schools or public academies
I think that all our options defined in
law already so I think that in this
section
3A that it should be reflective of the
rest of the statute
regardless of whether it's a policy in
this section of the statute
I think it has to be consistent with the
rest of uh the chapter
further discussion from the second
no
further discussion from the committee
representative Tanner
um so
I I'm confused about an approved private
school is it
what's it approved for is it approved
for uh providing an adequate education
is it approved for
um compulsory education
I have yet to find out
but it's approved for I mean I I know
the school board has to approve it but
what are they what's what are they
approving it for what's the approval
and I I can tell you that
I recall when we gave approval to
Freiburg Academy and the St Johnsbury
Academy
that
and that came about as results that we
were tuitioning students from this state
to those academies and uh there was a
lot of discussion back then in those
days whether we should be doing that at
all and Saint Jay called up and said hey
we we receive in revenue on tuition each
year from you in New Hampshire 1.5
million dollars
and so I found a place in statute and I
I unfortunately all my stickies are in
the old book not in the and maybe old
old book and and uh I had one there
where the commissioner of Education in
this state has given that the authority
to approve these schools based on the
fact that they are part of a state which
has the interstate government agreement
with us Vermont and Maine both do
and so that means if they're an approved
school by the department over there
either in Montpelier or in Augusta they
are approved here you know so at that
time Ginny Berry commissioner Barry
wrote a letter the next day saying those
were approved schools
now I'd have to find that area statute
which allows the commissioner to do that
so is it follow-up so we're talking
about approved by the commissioner or
approved by this local school board
um and uh does anybody know what the
process of that is I mean
how they go about approve I mean I can
see St John's you know a school approved
in Vermont by meeting the adequate
education policies there and also if
they meet the adequate education
policies in Maine find you know
reciprocal but I'm not sure how we go
about looking at every private school in
New Hampshire
whether they're approved or not or who
approves them whether there's a list or
do you know there isn't a list on the
Department of Education website there's
a list of approved private schools I've
approved and they've been approved by
the commissioner by the department yeah
yeah the commissioner is ultimately
responsible and we don't know what it's
uh by that kind of because the school
board has a responsibility to make sure
that the students that they support get
an adequate education that's in statute
that they have to get the opportunity
for an adequate education so I'm
assuming that if a school board approves
a private school
they've checked to make sure that that
school meets the standards of
adequate education here's the section
I'm talking to making references 194
colon 23
Dash B small B and it's Roman number two
and it reads the commissioner of the
Department of Education made through an
agreement with another state when such
State and New Hampshire are parties to
an interstate agreement allow New
Hampshire pupils to attend schools that
meet the standards established by one of
the two states
so it's basically what I just I said
that if it's approved by Augusta it's
good and I get that
that's on page 586. yep
I I would um looking at the chapter that
we're in the section of law
if in relation to the best interest of
the child if the superintendent agrees
that it's in the best interests of the
child
um
the superintendent shall initiate a
change of assignment uh to within this
current assigned School District
to another public school or public
Academy within the district or to a
Public School
public Academy or approved private
school in another District
right and that that's that turn my
problem is the term approved
um but this isn't in the best
intersection it's not the Manifest
um
well I I think they're all part of the
same in that if this parent the family
does not
um uh get agreement with the
superintendent they can appeal to the
school board which is the Manifest
education hardship provisions yeah
and ultimately then to the state board
right but I think but financial
responsibilities I think are different
in the best interest compared to the
Manifest educational hardship
section and
and
anyway I think this um
what what what's being what's being
modified here
um is um is is not what
I mean on page 507 in the right hand
column part uh paragraph d a parent or
Guardian can make a specific request to
a public school public Academy or
approved private school within the
district or outside of the district and
and then that language is repeated
um in paragraph F if the school board
finds that the student has a manifest
education hardship and it uses all that
language but in
but with Senate Bill 77 is doing is
modifying on the left hand column of 508
page 508
paragraph e where each School Board
shall establish a policy
um
which allow the school board with the
recognition to the of the superintendent
to take appropriate action including
assignment to another public school or
public Academy within the district or or
public Academy Public School outside of
the district this is adding approved
private school to both of those and it
it it really it changes the um
no it it yeah it changes the obligation
at the very top of the left hand column
of 508 it begins with the bottom of the
writing column of 507 where it talks
about the
the
tuition shall be computed according to
the school board of the district in
which the student resides shall approve
the tuition payment
um it's a it's a it's a different
um
I I don't know I but the school if you
look the school board shall establish a
policy that is consistent consistent
so they can't go off and say we're just
you know establishing no no I yeah
policy that says we're going to let the
kid go to the school district to the
north of us
right right but it's but it's it's
basically requiring every school board
to to have in place tuition agreements
with non-public schools
um
and um and school boards don't have to
do that right now they can certainly
have have specific contracts with
non-public schools consistent with State
policy but they don't actually have to
have a school board policy to have
contracts with non-public schools and
and that's what the modification in in E
is um is doing is is was there a
my recollection is the testimony that um
uh was that this was to make this
consistent with the rest of the section
um and I do believe that that was the
same
um uh rationale that was used in the
Senate when they passed this right so so
the rationale was essentially
housekeeping but this isn't a
housekeeping section that's that's
the you know just because certain
languages used in other paragraphs
doesn't mean that that this language
that that language where a parent May
request or a school board May approve
um that that language should also exist
in the in the paragraph that says the
school board shall establish policy
because they don't have to establish
policy on this they don't have to
establish tuition agreements with with
parents can certainly request school
boards can certainly approve on a
it does mention on page 509
Romans 7
and this section approved as school
tuition program means the school that
has been approved and contracted by the
school board to provide students with
the opportunity to acquire an adequate
right I'm not I'm not suggesting that
the that the non-public schools are in
any way less than adequate
um I'm just saying that that school
board doesn't have to establish a list
of non-public schools where they have
tuition uh programs too which is what he
is asking them to do as opposed to
Public Schools where where they have um
you know superintendent to
superintendent agreed on a manifest
hardship
um
representative leckers
I don't get your argument at all about
lists and all that kind of stuff it just
said it should establish a policy
consistent with State board's rules
which allow the school board with the
recommendation of the superintendent to
take appropriate action including
assignment two and then it lists those
three which are under those three are
under 193.3
um e no F3
is one of the options and so it makes
sense that if that's one of the options
that a school board should come up with
a policy of how they're going to deal
with those options because the options
are in the law right now and that's just
say all this says is you got to come up
with a policy for how you're going to
handle those options and they may decide
that their policy is never to send a kid
to a um approved private school that may
be their policy but they have to come up
with a policy because these three
options are what's in law right now in
not seeing we do have a motion on the
table and the motion was to
uh
OTP by represent cordelli and second by
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative blackis yes
representative fourth yes representative
Belcher yes representative try yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative courts
yellow yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Ellison no representative
representative Hall Nell representative
Balboni no Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no chairman yes
10 days 10 days yeah okay this shall
move Ito second
okay it's so we have a motion on the
table right now to itl
uh SBE 77 made by representative luno
and second by representative miler
further discussion
no
okay Madam clerk when you're ready
Vice chairman cordelli no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortiello no
representative Myler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman LED no
10 years 10 days
okay who's gonna write it
okay the next bill we have is sb109
this is relative to school safety and
represent dry I move ought to pass is
there a second
represent dry do you want to speak to
your motion
just a couple things to refresh our
memory that this
um
talks about the physical actual records
being able to be disclosed the impetus
for it is an incident at the school that
was a serious threat to school safety
and only a law enforcement level
information is transferred and they go
by the family education rights Privacy
Act and all applicable state law
so any further discussion on this I
believe the officer was from up north
right reps yeah
representative Cory young officer lads
yeah yeah yeah staff sergeant
okay so any further discussion on that
ma'am clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative yes representative Myler
yeah
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Paul yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin
representative Damon yes chairman yes
20a 0 Mays
for example yeah no objections to
consent got it
okay
next bill we have is
SB 136
and we are going to hold and not deal
with that bill today
so we're just not taking action on that
today so we're jumping over 136
to 151
and we heard that bill today
and
and let's see we had discussed out in uh
to retain that so who wants to make a
motion to retain
represent cordelli do you want to make a
motion
I move uh we retain spill
okay we have motion on the table to
retain SB 151 that's relative to mental
health education made by representative
cardallian second by representative luno
further discussion
not seeing any
Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative try yes representative
McDonnell yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes represent of
course yellow yes representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
blue now yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes 20 years
okay
we're up to 152 right now this is
relative to New Hampshire Workforce
training programs I'd like to have a
little discussion if we could please on
that before we take a motion on the
table
um
uh represent Cornell was there any
discussion of this bill yesterday at the
pte meeting you attended yes there was
and they were very excited that we
possibly would be passing this because
it could combine welding with scuba
diving
um make a
certificate to enable a growing
Workforce
um they were thinking they would be
started in one CTA te location
um possibly I think they were thinking
Portsmouth because the pool is walkable
distance from the CTE Center and so they
could just combine the two programs
um but they are always looking for new
um certificates for the growing changes
that are happening in the workforce
right now
was there any discussion on the on the
offshore wind industry Workforce
Training Center committee
that's part of this bill no no there
wasn't
Is there further discussion from the
group regarding this bill before we take
some action on it
yeah
thank you Mr chair yes well let's let's
Senator Waters wasn't at the meeting
yesterday he was on video
um and he did speak to the um growing
field of wind and how many jobs it would
provide and how in other states that are
doing it it's it's very successful
so
okay thank you Mr chair
um I would say the um the Marine traits
it sounds absolutely amazing
um having done some time with the
shipyard myself it's definitely a good
career field there's definitely jobs
that need to be filled in that field
that said I don't have any interest
personally and further subsidizing and
already very expensive energy source in
wind energy I think it's entirely likely
that if we train energy jobs or rather
wind energy jobs here because of the
minimal Coastline we have and because of
the political environment in New
Hampshire it's entirely likely these
jobs are going to leave the state
so I would not be for this bill unless
we can pull the Marine trades out and do
further discussion on the bill
one of the things that we noticed was
that this commission offshore wind
energy Workforce Training Center
committee as no legislators on it
regarding the the commission makeup yeah
oh yeah okay
yes represent Woodcock thank you
um
I was I sat through this on the video
screen I was I was excited about
listening to the option the potential
for growth in New Hampshire and growth
in the workforce uh in all fields of
marine and alternative power options and
uh listening about the bouncing things
on the in the ocean uh versus being the
stabilized ones uh for options I think
this is terrific for New Hampshire uh
and I don't concur with my neighbor here
to the left about the political
political options here in New Hampshire
uh there there was some question uh that
several of us had regarding the makeup
of the commission but uh correct me if
I'm uh if I'm wrong here uh Jen that do
the fact this is not a legislative
commission we don't have to have elected
um
we
seemed to be much more instinctive
yes representative thank you again
thanks just to add to that um it sounds
to me that it is a lot like
any other program in a CT Center they
all have an advisory Council that is
sort of out in the field that
specializes so there's a bridge between
the workforce and what the kids are
learning so that's how I view that
that's their makeup or recommended
makeup of that advisory Council
to the program so it's a little bit
different than the one that represented
Cornell's on seeing that she's on that
as represented from the general court
the whole CTE though
not one that's right are you doing the
whole right it is different yeah it's a
little different this one the the reason
why the question was brought up was we
have an area statue it's 1449 colon 49.
which was just passed last year and
represented that was represented Evil's
cleanup bill on committees and
commissions and as stated within that
any new commissions or committees which
they use the word committee to also
cover Commission
can have no more than 15 members on it
no less than five of which over half
those members on must be elected
officials
that's that's what we have new that's
new in legislation so so apparently it's
not applicable to this particular
thing right here
further discussion yes representative
Miler yeah I would move us to ought to
pass this I mean it's the bipartisan
bill that's coming out of the Senate uh
it it provides uh alternative Workforce
work for Workforce path
I just don't see the problems one of the
things we found that even in the Marine
area up in the Lakes area for example of
how you're going to begin to have young
people begin to learn how to deal with
motors
Etc
I just think this is a good thing I
don't understand why we're
messing around with it
I would move to octopath at the
appropriate time
representative we're still in discussion
though yeah I just wanted to add to what
you just said my excitement for this was
the wind distance industry so if you go
north you'll see a lot of
you know wind
um
Towers
from upstate New York there's a lot of
going from Lake Champlain all the way
over to Canton through Potsdam as you're
going from the Lake Champlain area to
Ellenberg with further west
it's solid solid turbines the
unfortunate thing is the communities
down below are all looking like they're
bankrupt they've sold the property out
they left the land
and but Upstate New York's never been a
prosperous place so
any rate
representative
yeah I guess
the idea we're setting up a fund
for the the part of which will be used
for this commission but my question is
who then
oversees the com or committee rather
who then oversees
the committee the money the spending of
the money
Etc I'm not sure how this is
all work since we're not part of it
chairman lud yes looking at line 18 to
20 and I agree with representative Lucas
it says the commissioner of education is
authorized to establish procedures for
the use of funds and to disperse funds
as recommended by the offshore wind
industry Workforce Training Center
committee
I agree I don't know where the oversight
further discussion on this
is it worth amending to put in some
elected officials on it
no
represent cordelli
yeah I just have some difficulty and we
talked to it was mentioned any way of
the industrial wind towers we see around
New Hampshire which is called Ridge line
um Power
um is the most inefficient
and we've seen
um pictures of
blades that have come down and are
buried in the ground
um what happens after 20 years when a
tower is decommissioned what happens to
that what we'll find out you know maybe
another 15 years I guess
um I I see the same problems with
offshore wind and I don't know what the
solution is there uh I've read about the
problems they're having off the coast of
New Jersey
with fish and whales dying and no one is
really sure of of the reason
um and if that's related to the
beginnings of installation of offshore
wind there so I I have
um reservations about
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman
I don't want to see the Marine section
go down because of a committee on wind
Force but I'm having a problem with this
committee because here we are in
education it's talked about talking
about Workforce training
there's no legislators on this and it
reports just to the governor and then
the Bia it just sounds like it's
in Congress yeah in in this bill and I
would really
rather divide it and make sure that the
thank you Mr chair
so I'm in favor of the bill I was going
to note that both in the testimonial you
heard in the hearing and if you read
lines
sorry let me refund it here 17 to 19 on
the first page the funding is from
businesses and industries it's not from
the state we're not funding it
um
I think having a committee to explore
offshore wind is not the same thing as
setting up offshore win
and we need to have people learn and
understand and communicate about it
um I think it's renewable energy is very
much the direction we should go in
there have been these kinds of wind
um
I'm not sure what the right terminology
is but for lack of better word Towers
on the Sea Coast of Spain for at least
20 years and they are very safe and very
productive they've been well established
and they've expanded over time
other countries are way ahead of us in
renewable energy we need to catch up
[Music]
representative uh Ellison
thank you Mr chairman move the process
along I'll second uh there's no emotion
there's no motion on the table you did
okay no motion on the table
I'm
I'm a little I agree with uh Margaret I
think she's going to representative
prayer the the commission and the the
function of the of the task force
although is representative uh uh Damon
said it's not connected to the
government money I just can't believe
we're sitting here talking about uh
possibly negating a program that's going
to teach basic marine technology that's
going to prove all kinds of training in
addition to Marie Han Solo because of
potential whales dying in New Jersey if
it makes sense who knows that's the main
we're talking about what's going to
happen here how we can train our
youngsters coming out of high school and
call it a young adults or audio high
school and college in an inexpensive way
to get a high-tech skill and we're
saying no we don't want to do it because
the committee's not right I think we'll
move in the wrong direction I don't know
I thought we were all concerned about
the environment certainly the uh the
same animals are part of the environment
representative Belcher you're recognize
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
offer a brief correction I think to
something we heard a few minutes ago
suggesting that the state is not paying
for this line 14 does in fact say uh
shall include State Appropriations
designated for the purposes of the fund
so that there are there will be State
funds going toward this
CT funds it's cool great
any other teacher programs represent
Lucas and Anna coming across
two points one is just
um There Are Places out west that have
these windmills and the problem that
they're having is they are
non-compostable by a group degradable
Etc and when one of them comes down it
will completely fill a landfill
and they don't know what to do with them
and they're trying to figure out because
they're made to last they don't break
down but they don't break down and so it
is an issue that's just on the ecology
part of it but
um
why do we need
to do a committee
for industry to figure out what might
work it's all industry to figure out
whether or not it makes sense especially
if it's industry money unless they're
looking for our money they could do
their own they've certainly done it for
all kinds of other programs where
industry has gotten together said this
is what we want this is what it should
look like
Etc recommended it to Community College
CTE and they've adopted it so why are we
getting involved with that part I would
love to see the first part go through
representative cascaden
I I think it's a shame that we are
talking so much about anti of this the
way that I'm viewing it again it's just
my view is that this is the opportunity
for an additional Korean technical ad
um
Pathway to a profession not necessarily
being the installer or the wind towers
but to study the science of it and all
the jobs that go with Marine
I don't remember Marine trades
um and so it's another program that I
foresee would be run under the Jeff
beards Department as another Career and
Technical Ed program
and let them figure out how that's going
to look and their committee like the
other committees like culinary arts
welding Auto Building Trades they have
industry related partners
who work with the school and a parent
Representatives
representation to always evaluate and
assess the program
based on the market
and it gives kids opportunities to look
for other
um Pathways
um it's just like Colebrook just got a
new CTE Center and I think they're
adding I don't remember if they added
culinary arts as well but
um you know they're looking for the
balsam's resort and training kids to
start getting into that line of work
well you could talk about well what's
the point is it food waste uh you know
it's not sanitary it's not this it's not
that I think we need to look at this as
a program and then let the school
districts who are Regional Centers do
the rest
further discussion representative Damon
just want to remind everybody that the
league of conservation voters supported
further discussion
okay we're going to take a caucus for
foreign
I think this is going to be a vote your
just voted as you see it
could I just add um
I'm confused about
um
the committee
and what they're supposed to be doing
um
it talks about this to study the need
to build and stay up offshore
Workforce training centers
um
but it talks about CTE at the same time
I I don't know if
um if this committee is supposed to
um promote development of the industry
and study how to move forward with the
industry or if it's
um related to CTE because it talks about
CTE in line 32 in various but then it
also talks about
leasing and capital expenditures for
facilities and so forth so I'm confused
about what this committee does and the
fact that as representative pedernal
pointed out the commissioner of
education is in charge of the funds and
distribution of funds but he doesn't
even get a copy of the report they
produce
no
on 29 times 29 and 30 on page one and
then one and two in my page two
they're supposed to report to the right
the income and expenditures
yeah but now what the committee is doing
but the commissioner is a member of the
committee
technology thank you Mr chair I move all
representative McDonald do you have
anything to do
yes we just had a great discussion and
we heard good arguments on both sides
however our CTE programs are largely
successful we should support expansions
to the program because this would
increase the ability of students to be
trained in careers and increase their
chances of success in the workforce and
Vice chairman cordelli no
representative blackis no
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher no
representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative Corey tiello no
representative Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascadin yes
15 years
okay
is anyone doing a Minority Report is
SBE 155 relative to adoption of school
administrative unit budgets
let's have a little discussion on this
first I think there's a little bit of
foreign
school administrative unit budgets
remember we had this budget manager from
Penny Baker in here to discuss that and
my notes are not really I was listening
more to them than not taking notes which
I should have taken notes but he said
the contracts need Clarity
implementation subject to interpretation
has Dre been involved in this the answer
was no
um
Bob at the ballot process is problematic
why alternative I'm reading my writing
here I need a little cursive here why
alternate process for all districts lead
um
in basic what is the need for it
I don't represent cascaden you don't
is
foreign
[Music]
if you were a single District you could
still not amend or change
the Warren article in any way prior to
the vote
and we have in our town certainly
throughout the history of the Town had
things that were very divided that
people were very much in disagreement
and by the end of the either town
meeting or deliberative session we had
come up with a plan that we could
support and then passed and so I would
hate it
for that not to be able to happen it
makes sense if it's multiple districts
because then you got this one voting
this you know amending this way and then
that would be chaos
but if it's a single District
um there's no reason why they can't be
done and then come up with something
that everybody can agree to and they did
recently send me a suggestion for an
amendment
which I can put in
but I'm not going to do that if
everybody here is just planning on
idealing this because what's the point
but if it looks like people want to move
forward at all I will happily put that
in
further discussion represent cordelli uh
thank you
um I believe we had uh testimony from
a representative that this was uh all
about transparency and administrative
costs
um I did
go and find the doe report that was
referred to the a12d central office
Personnel form that does require each
fall districts to report the number of
superintendents assistant
superintendents Finance professionals
Etc
so they'd already do that reporting to
doe each year
um
I would think it would be easier to make
that information post that information
for the public then to
go all go through all this and have a
separate SAU
budget vote
um so in this case I think simpler is is
better
um
and so I I think I will vote the same
further discussion represent Alexis
yes I not knowing the name of that form
one of my constituents and I had gone
through trying to get this information
because we were told it's on the website
so we went on I platform and we could
find the immediate administrator you
know the superintendent whatever but not
all the things on that list because we
had no idea what it was called or that
there was a form
and we know more than a lot of people
right
so
I don't think the the
public can find those but the other part
of that is by dividing it out just like
we divide out the teacher salaries and
the other things it means that they can
vote on
that section separately it's not it's so
it's it's transparency number one they
can see what it is but number two they
can vote on it
and that might mean
that they don't vote down the whole
school district funding if this is
rolled into it and they say it's too
high but they may vote just on the you
know it may save one or the other of
them depending upon
what the budget is and what people feel
but I just it seems to make sense to me
where we're voting on teacher salaries
and all those other things let a vote on
this too and let people see what it is
further discussion it represent Myler
I believe that
this committee
dealt with House Bill 563
in the pre earlier
and this committee voted 19 to 1 to itl
almost an identical bill from
dealing with this topic so I would I
would hope that we would con continue
that because I don't think it's
necessary and I thank representative
cordelli for pointing out the report
so not seeing any further discussion
here representative cordelli do you want
to make a motion
I would love to
I would move it up
so we have a motion on the table to itl
made by represent Cornell he's second by
representative Miler
um representative Cordell you've already
spoken to it do you need to speak again
I do not representative Miler nor do I
anybody else
Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas no
representative Ford
yes
representative try
no
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble no
representative pedernal
no
Representative no representative Myler
yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
Madam Clerk I need to change my vote to
and then
good will there be a Minority Report
okay
last bill on the docket today is 213.
is relative to educational institutional
I will open this up to discussion and to
have the discussion first
representative cardelli
thank you
um
I I guess I don't have a large problem
with
the intent but I have a problem with
execution and issues related to privacy
um
there is
um RSA 189
68-a dealing with student online
personal information and
um
any
internet based site that is primarily
for K-12 purposes for Education
um
has certain requirements
I don't know if
this bill is in compliance with that I
wrote to
director beard
who forwarded my concerns to
the doe
legal
council
who has not yet gotten back to us with
an answer to my concerns
but the whole issue as I mentioned I
think prior is relation to what's called
digital badging and digital credentials
which is clearly what this involves
I have issues
I can just name off a few of them
who can create and upload content
who can access and review data
can the student or the parents modify or
delete
information that's on the site who has
ownership of that data
can student data be deleted Upon A
account cancellation graduation or
request of the student
who has access to see that information
who has abilities to download that
information can info personal
information from the site be sold or
rented to third parties
can user information be transferred to a
third party in the event that the
company is merged or acquired it is
unclear whether parental consent is
required before personal information is
collected or disclosed
parental consent notice and method for
submission is not provided for can
parents of minors have access to see
what credentials are being added for the
student
it's possible that
um unfavorable information
could be added to the site we don't know
and will the student or their parents
know about that
would parents be allowed to withdraw
consent for a further collection of
information
um
so those are some of my concerns about
the
the system that is being discussed here
in general
and without further provision for
security and privacy related to this
information I I can't support it at this
time
I should turn on my bike though
I I got a question for you uh
representative cordelli then uh in the
amendment was was presented to us by uh
Senator Waters
it replaces uh paragraph two with a new
paragraph
and within that Amendment it speaks to
attaining written parental consent
and goes on
and it talks about uh require the
provision of personally identifiable
information so if if
in fact the parent has provided that
consent is the school district or the
CTE Center still going to be responsible
for uh
what happens to that student information
is there a liability issue there at all
I I'm curious I I think as you said I
like the intent of this bill
um but I'm I'm I also want to know if is
that enough
new paragraph number two enough to put
the onus of all this onto the on the
parent
yeah yeah I I think it it helps
um but from my mind it doesn't go far
enough
um
and my concern with these types of
systems it does not apply just to here
for CTE it's my intention to
um
hopefully next year or the year after
depending on what happens
to bring legislation that would also
affect the community college system and
the university system because I think
representative yeah Mr chair I just have
a procedural question and we have the
March 28th uh Amendment from Senator
Waters and we have been given uh another
amendment from representative McDonald
and I'm not sure how you want to deal
with the substance of the bill vis-a-vis
these two amendments and how you want to
go forward in dealing with these
amendments in relationship to the main
the main Bill okay the first amendment I
spoke to is one that was provided by
Senator Waters at the time the bill was
presented so I thought I'd look at that
first we're not going to take any action
on any of this until we have them both
explained to us
and so that looking at remember 1269 H
which is representative McDonald's uh
um Amendment uh perhaps we ought to you
know does everybody have Senator Waters
Amendment
I can let's just read that right there
what I had
uh then then what we'll do is we'll jump
over the senator Waters Amendment right
now and go right to represent McDonald's
Amendment um and representative McDonald
uh could you please explain what you've
done here with your Amendment yes I
would like to
just now was mentioned some safety
concerns that with unattended
consequences that differ from the intent
of the bill as proposed so I hope my
Amendment addresses some of those
concerns it just adds one sentence to
the end of section one that states
nothing in this section shall encourage
student involvement in careers as
influencers social media models internet
personalities or otherwise diminish
student safety and the last two words
are really the heart of the amendment
student safety I am confident that no
one wants to endanger or infringe upon
the safety of students and this
amendment is not to discourage students
from participating in those kind of
activities but it just recognizes that
school is not the place to encourage
thank you so you're you're talking about
the platform
that they may be using to for their
technical education or or that aspect of
learning
no platform will be used that's going to
more than that yeah
some of these platforms as well it might
not be the platform that's the issue but
it's how the student chooses to engage
in that platform a lot of these tools
can be used for marketing and career
purposes but there's other students who
may be pressured from societal
influences to do maybe unsafe behaviors
and school isn't the place to encourage
that
McDonald excuse my um
my age here
um but I I would like if you could if
you could Define these terms of
influencers
social media models internet
personalities
um I I don't know how those are used if
you could Define those for me I'd
appreciate it yes and I am willing to
play around with the wording of these if
it's something like that that would
cause this amendment or the bill to fail
but in regards to those terms those are
influencers are somebody who through
their social media accounts establishes
a career where social media itself is
the career and the intent was stated
that CTE programs are the career and
social media is just a tool to advocate
for that these are just kind of careers
in social media themselves such as
posting content online sometimes nude
content naked photos and just things
like that that would diminish student
safety
represent keskin thanks I have
um actually two questions I don't know
if I might yes go ahead um uh many of us
might
um
be familiar with Girl Scout or Boy Scout
merit badges and used to have a
um a sash you know you sewed your merit
badge on this this is like those those
badges are now digital and that they are
part of a software system where you can
add badges for
um or credentials for certain things
like even you know passing a course in
college or things like that
um
right but do you want that all right
paper you wouldn't want that or would it
be because there's a chance that an
outside entity would
my concern is that the the privacy of
that information if someone I I might
not necessarily know what someone is
posting as a quote on a credential to my
account
um you know I want to make sure that I
have access to look at that or if I'm a
minor that my parent would have access
to look at that information those types
um
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair um and I'd like to
kind of follow up a little bit with uh
what cordelli was speaking of too it's
similar but not exactly the same
um I can Envision that if we move toward
a system as as we say digital badging or
something to that effect
we're going to create an incentive
structure that creates something of an
industry standard for hiring practices
for saying that this student has this
competency and therefore they are good
to go in this and the problem is if
we're going if we're going to
third-party social media for this sort
of thing social media they have their
own terms of service that have to be
abided by and they don't go by the U.S
Constitution I can I can speak
personally as somebody who has been at
one point or another probably suspended
from just about every social media
platform that exists
people
[Laughter]
I don't think I I don't think we want to
create a situation where where students
in high school need to feel like they're
walking on eggshells to at all times
make sure that their social media
presence isn't being compromised in
order to go get a job thereafter and I
think we need to really be cautious
about what kind of
sort of social control over job
functions we're providing to third-party
companies
yes represent cascadden um
just to add air information and I don't
know if this
solves what you're thinking but a few
years back actually before I
I want to say I don't know maybe five
six years ago
it was a law that said all school
districts had to create data security
plans
and they had to inventory every single
piece of software that was being used in
the district and then we had to purchase
goguardian which flags every individual
student that might use a word
that might not be appropriate like
if they did a an essay and in the word
they had
Square no they wouldn't have a swear
word like I don't know kill or something
that would raise attention to the safety
of the child
and I'm wondering if if their CTE
software that is third party
why wouldn't it go through the same
vetting process that all
software so I'm trying to see what what
what is actually done to vet all of that
public software I mean because kids use
Prodigy and Naviance and a whole bunch
of softwares
that are a third party but they're
vetted first and then there is a guard
system
within the district because we buy that
software like a security system where
the I.T staff can pick up specifically
which student is entering something
inappropriate or accessing some
accessing something from the outside
so I I don't know if that's enough based
on the interpretation of this bill or
whether this is still required but it's
not something as a superintendent I
would ever worry about with the
right I did receive a communication from
Jeff beard here
back on March 22.
and I'll read it seeing I only have one
copy here in front of me
he says the current proposal is to amend
RSA 189 colon 70
educational institution policies on
social media you need to open up more
than social media
I would suggest the amendment belongs in
RSA 189 colon 66 Roman 5. so if you have
that right now you might be looking at
that RSA 189 colon 66 Roman 5.
RSA 189 colon 66 is the general data
inventory and policies publication
statute
Section 5 is the provision that
currently requires each Lea to develop a
data and privacy governance plan
the issue we are running into is the
district's data privacy and governance
plans are that they have to have signed
a DPA agreement with the Consortium
this is the broader provision and covers
all sorts of platform slash digital
tools I agree and if it's possible
amending RSA 189's colon 66 would
address the issue we've discussed of CTE
teachers and students finding it
difficult to access industry recognized
credential assignment assessments and
Industry standard tools such as Adobe
Pro and SolidWorks and CTE programs
so there there is a recommendation came
from him to change where this is is it
wise that we take a little bit of time
you know represent Cordelia said that he
has some issues with
personal data I think we all probably do
but there's also according to the
director here we're going into the wrong
area statute
represent miler I I think that might be
wise I think I I want to go back to the
original intent of this bill the
original intent of the bill was to
provide opportunities for students to
get access to platforms
that they can't right now and in getting
access to those platforms it might give
them an opportunity to become certified
in a particular line of study or a
particular area so I I want to be
respectful of Representative cordelli's
concerns about privacy we've had that
before this committee many times but I
also don't want to lose the intent of
the bill that allows students to get
more than what they currently have and I
I thought originally well maybe uh uh
Senator Waters Bill dealing with a
parent to provide that sense of I was
okay with that so I just I guess uh
representative of that I just I don't
want to lose the the merits of trying to
get students opportunities to gain
greater access to what they currently
can so that they can advance themselves
and their own knowledge and perhaps
their own certification opportunity so
perhaps taking a little more time to
look at some of the stuff would be good
because I don't I I I like the bill
the intent of the bill I guess is what
I'm looking for yeah I I concur with you
I think the bill has real good Merit
good purpose
uh if we have some things we have to
tweak or get a better handle on we ought
to take some time to do that
representative Cornell Thank you doesn't
Senator Waters Amendment refer to RSA
189 colon 66 and insert moment six after
five
to fix
that
yeah
yes
I'm not sure I understand the problem
and why we are changing anything I read
through
the section you gave us
189.665 yeah
but it doesn't as far as I can tell say
they can't do these things
um so I'm wondering is there some is
there an RSA someplace else
that we're missing but it says that they
can't do these things
is it 189.74
[Music]
maybe the one we're working on
because refer putting it in five
it just says minimum standards for
privacy and security of student employee
data based on best practices for local
education agencies
so they have to have they have to
develop a dating privacy governance plan
Etc but it doesn't say what it is
it just says what it has to fi the
things it has to take into consideration
so according to that we don't need any
of this
so what is it that saying that we do
need this stuff and so I guess I have to
look at this other 189
okay
property
food
students participating in career Expo uh
exploration or Career Technical
education May with written per parent
consent register for technology
technology platforms and services to be
used as part of the students program of
study so it means if it's part of the
program of study I would assume that
that's been approved by the instructor
or the or the course the program pardon
me
okay I looked back at that yeah
representative
um
yeah I don't see why putting it where he
suggested we put it makes any sense
because really the part that says that
they can't do those things is
189.70 we says that they can't require
or request a student or prospective
student to disclose or provide access to
a personal social media account
but that's a personal one not a school
one
yeah it's an exception obviously I think
the same thing
yeah but the rule has to do
right but the rule has to do with
personal accounts and we're not talking
about personal accounts we're talking
about school accounts so I'm not sure
how it all fits together are we talking
personal accounts
that's my question what are we talking
about I think I might be able to help
clarify a little bit of this because we
seem to be getting some wires crossed uh
per that uh letter you just read we were
talking about some Adobe programs and
trying to get certification in these
according to current law social media
account is defined an account service or
profile on a social networking website
that is used by a current or prospective
student primarily for personal
Communications Adobe is not a social
networking website there is nothing in
this current law that would prohibit
utilizing that service or obtaining
certifications using that service or to
count unless you are then trying to link
that account to a private social media
to perhaps advertise on your social
media that you've done some you've met
some certification on Adobe
he speaks to recognize industry
recognize credential assessments and
Industry standard tools such as Adobe
Etc so
that doesn't sound like it's social to
me it's not Adobe is not a social media
platform right
representative Tanner and represent
Damon um just want to mention that it's
not just the Career technical schools
that are having an issue with this that
um Sunapee I actually went and and met
with the I.T director there and and they
have courses elective courses like
um you know graphic design and they need
to download some of these different
programs and and the programs with them
have maybe badges with you know located
with them but um and they're having
trouble deciding which ones they can
which ones they can't so even though
it's not a social media thing where you
know you have friends and you're
bouncing stuff over a whole bunch of
people
it still has the the different levels of
you know competition or different levels
that you get to and and uh drafting
programs or coding programs you can get
those online for free but there's always
it says in in this in um
18970 the part where a men looking to
amend it defines social and media
account
as one used primarily for personal
Communications and yet this amendment
put in was for Career and Technical but
that's not talking about something used
primarily for personal Communications
that's talking about something used for
the classroom
platform technology platforms and
services used as part of the students
program of study and I'm wondering
are we putting these in the right place
do they I mean one talks about
one thing personal primary primarily it
says for personal Communications but the
stuff they're doing with the CTE is not
primarily for personal Communications
it's for study right and so
represented uh Damon did you have your
hand up earlier
okay represent dry
thank you uh can somebody explain to me
why the amendment from Senator Waters
and the new paragraph on the original
Bill are almost identical I think their
words are a little different but they
say exactly the same thing except for
the original bill says such technology
and services shall have a direct
connection to the student content areas
of study so why are we putting the same
thing in two places if we adopted the
amendment
represent Damon
so they're not actually entirely the
same because in the original bill on
line 12 it says Parental opt-in this one
says
well yeah I'm saying this Senator Waters
Amendment replaces paragraph two and
puts it in a new place
so it takes away you just X Out
paragraph two and put this amendment
so it's not it's not the same thing
twice you're doing away with
it says amend the bill by replacing
section two
he also changes where to put it it's a
different RSA
right but this doesn't get rid of oh
this gets rid of this in this okay got
it got it got it got it thank you so it
just moves it to that other place thank
you Belcher and then representative Ford
thank you and if I may just to briefly
recall some of the testimony I believe
from from a sponsor
um or somebody adjacent they they
referred to this colloquially as the
LinkedIn Bill none of the things that
were described that we've heard so far
are social media that would be
prohibited under current law LinkedIn
however is social media does have a
private terms of service they do have if
I'm not mistaken the capacity to collect
Badges and such and I think that would
it seems to me to be the real purpose
represent Damon you're sinking
thank you
the way that people communicate today is
different in many cases than what most
of this committee grew up with and has
more familiarity with
one of the ways that students can Market
themselves for internships apprentices
jobs
further
um
education is through the digital badging
so we do need to address the
considerations that have been raised in
the safety
but I think we need to do it somewhat
expeditiously because we are
shortchanging these kids if they don't
have
this way of communicating
representative Ford
I started out by saying I'm not of this
world I don't know these programs I I
couldn't turn on a machine and make any
of them work period end of sentence now
having said that I hear this discussion
in two different ways that they're two
separate needs I hear through my wife
and all the students she works with the
need for digital badging I did you but
the purpose of it when you apply for a
job is to show that you know it
not to have access to it not to be
connected to it but that you know how to
use it that's what a transcript tells
you you know a mathematics you know
history you know whatever whatever the
thing you have to know is in your
transcript it tells you that it doesn't
happen to mention
digital badges
I'm wondering if one way to keep people
from divulging or be susceptible to and
I share your concern about the records
being kept off campus so to speak in a
private company that profits from
manipulating you that's the nature of
the business
what if you could transfer the badging
credits only to the transcript
and require that to be listed on the
transcript as an official confirmation
of expertise
or it doesn't have to be the school
contract it can be whatever we can
create one
but the idea is to separate the this is
what you have expertise in from the
actual thing of oh gee I can click over
here and then go into this thing it's
just an idea
representative Luna
thanks Mr chair yeah I I I think your
your suggestion you're in representative
miler's suggestion earlier that that um
that maybe we get some
um
another amendment uh
put together possibly with the
assistance of Mr beard
um and and to go after and I and I think
representative Belcher actually was
right on it when he talked about uh
LinkedIn and the badges and they use
that platform as sort of like a
Matchmaker between
um employers and potential employees and
and
you know and it it does sort of speed
things along there's still an interview
you still got to prove you know what you
know but um
but that that's how I think a lot of
these a lot of our students
are connecting with with potential
employers and
um
and being able to have that badging
process work in conjunction with the CTE
Workforce Development programs
um but I think getting some support from
um
from Mr beard would be I think that's a
good idea and I also remember what
represent Tanner was speaking to
um that they're in my high school in
whitual high school they're making
canoes right in the high school out of
fiberglass and wood strippers and all
that that
um that they race with
and that's certainly not a CTE Center
but it's also utilizing what's out there
on the internet to help them design and
and uh even you know to to Market some
of those canoes that they're making so
there's a lot to this that goes well
beyond just CT I think
so I just kind of had this Epiphany
um
thinking again about my my colleague
here dealing with security Etc
we're not dealing with second and third
graders here
yeah we're dealing with people who are
are getting ready to go to the workforce
and so although I want to be concerned
about that about about security Etc
the age group that that we're focusing
in here are these are folks who are just
getting ready to go out into the
workforce
and there are risks when you turn on
that computer regardless of what you're
going to do
and so I I I don't know where I came
with that but I was just I was just
thinking that these are these are almost
adults here
we need to be concerned I'm not I'm not
denying that but we also have to think
about what the age group is that we're
dealing with here and so
um just wanted to share my opinion we
also have to go watch out for the
computer is owned by the school district
and the liability that hangs with a
school district for allowing something
to occur or that may come back to hit
the school district as a result of the
parent being ripped off over what
happened or the kid themselves
so there's there's a lot to this
particular issue I think it's wise that
we we form a small subcommittee on this
right now and find people that would
like to work on this and get a hold of
Jeff beard and try to square it away
because we all agree I think the intent
is wonderful
uh we just have to make sure our data is
protected and we're allowing access
who would like to work with uh is there
anybody here would like to actively work
on it into this
that would long to come in so I see two
okay if if those are before you head out
here today would you please come over
and give us your names right down right
here and we'll record those and then
we'll set up a meeting with Jeff beard
get going on this and hopefully we can
have this come back to us quickly here
okay I think can I just ask if let's get
done as soon as possible because all of
the ctes are so concerned because so
many students aren't being able to get
their credentials and and able to access
the platforms that they need to I think
it's it's in districts that aren't
recognizing that it's being used as
career platforms and they they can't
separate from social platforms which is
which is the problem and I think they
need legislation to tell them I think
it'd be important that we pick somebody
out of it over at doe to help us out as
well
uh Jeff's great uh on on lot we you and
I have not both met and worked with him
he's fantastic but let's get somebody
yeah
how do you spell his last name
okay
yeah okay
so we also need somebody who's familiar
with the law because some of these like
this one part with the ctes neither one
of those places is the right place to
put it so we need to figure out where to
put it so we have access to doe
attorneys so we need them too yeah which
appeared it didn't work uh afforded
information uh to uh Liz Brown
foreign
Elizabeth Brown's already been involved
with this so she's she's an attorney
over doe so she can work with us on this
as well I got the memo here from her
so with that we're finished what we had
to do today uh let's talk about what
we're doing in the next week here
so everybody's on the same wave like we
did receive a new bill today is 218 as I
mentioned this morning as sb218 we have
to have a hearing on that bill
yeah
I had to take mine off the web earlier
uh see
establishing early educator professional
and if the bill establishes in the
Department of Education an early
educator professional development grant
program towards school districts funds
for their local professional development
a mouthful
so that has to be put in the docket here
and looking at where we are we do have
uh we also excuse me on 419. I'm 419
that's Wednesday
at 10 o'clock we had SP 135 215 216 and
272 and anything that came out of this
that we didn't do today would be latched
on there
um I'm looking at we're going to have in
Repsol a very busy day on the 18th
with 272 that's the parent Rights bill
I'm not going to exec that bill the next
day I'm going to let things sort of
simmer down a little bit and then we
will come back and we'll exec that bill
on 425 that'd be April 25th when we're
doing 266. that's the one we got the
side by side
um
and so we'll put in 272 on that day and
218 as a hearing
we're gonna have to have that hearing
and then we
um if we we could possibly exec it on
that same day or we may have to come
back and exact that at a later date
so
on top of that we're going to have to
have this subcommittee right here now
I've got McDonnell cordelli Hall leckis
were there anybody else over here that
wanted to join in that that we have to
get time with Jeff and Liz
are available Patty
I'm scheduling did I hear correctly that
the EFA oversight committee was canceled
for the 17th yes do we have a a date
that's been I don't please who who's
chairing that
big award Rufus bruises yeah right yeah
okay but there's no it hasn't been I've
seen it open up do we know why Wisconsin
I think just
and I think it's workload also on the
17th we have a work session we do
on 266. that's the side-by-side Bill
dealing with adequacy
and please look that over I've looked at
it since and every time I look at it I
okay so when we start this time we're
just going to have to go through it and
we're gonna have to note things where we
see changes and write those changes down
so when we get through if we have to
make amending language or whatever we're
going to do with that bill
to me it's looking like there's so much
there we're almost getting into a
retained mode but um
let's see
yeah and that will all appear in the
and let's see 218 that's an early bill
that one in 151 were the early bills we
got to take care of so with that I guess
anything else
no we're good is there a Minority Report
on sb155
yes Lakers yes
I'll make copies of this